The SCP Foundation does their best to live
up to their famous namesake: They secure and
contain anomalies and monsters from all around
the world - or sometimes even off-world - and
protect the public from the dangers that these
strange entities might pose.
However, despite their efforts to maintain
security and keep their subjects under lock
and key, there are sometimes creatures so
clever, so devious, and so determined to escape
their captivity and wreak havoc on the world,
that even the SCP foundation struggles to
keep them from getting free.
One example is SCP-035, or the Possessive
Mask.
SCP-035 is one of the most dangerous test
subjects in SCP Foundation custody, and its
mere presence at the Foundation has resulted
in untold damage, death, and destruction.
It seems innocent enough, to the untrained
eye.
The mask, which resembles a classic white
porcelain “comedy” mask - though it occasionally
changes its expression to “tragedy” - has
been in existence since at least the 1800s.
In the late 19th century the Foundation discovered
the mask in a sealed crypt beneath an abandoned
home in Venice.
It is unknown how it got there, or how the
Foundation knew to look for it.
If there ever was an explanation for its discovery,
it has long since been removed or redacted
from the Foundation’s archives.
You’re probably wondering: How can a simple
mask leave multiple seasoned Foundation employees
dead?
Well, like everything at the SCP foundation,
this mask is not what it seems.
There is a reason its classification is “keter”,
a designation that refers to an entity that’s
excessively difficult to contain - and it
couples this difficulty with a pronounced
hostility toward human life, and the ability
to cause widespread destruction in the event
of a containment breach.
These are qualities that the poor unfortunate
souls assigned to guard SCP-035 would come
to understand all too well.
The Possessive Mask is a parasitic entity,
constantly seeking out a host willing to put
it on.
Any human being in the mask’s proximity
experiences a sudden, unexplainable urge to
put it on and once they do, there’s no going
back.
SCP Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask, their brain
waves are replaced with an alternative pattern,
this one coming from the mask, rendering the
host effectively brain dead.
Once the host’s brain function has been
eliminated, the mask takes over, piloting
their body and even speaking through them.
However, the mask can only occupy a host for
a small amount of time before the body begins
to decay and decompose, eventually rotting
away completely, leaving nothing but desiccated
flesh and bones where there once was a person.
SCP-035 is capable of possessing any humanoid
being, whether that’s an actual human being
or a lifeless humanoid shape.
Despite all their research, the SCP Foundation
unknowingly gave the Mask all the tools and
resources it needed to break containment...
and leave a trail of bodies in its wake.
For a time, the mask was given “host privileges,”
meaning that it was purposely allowed to occupy
a host in order to speak with the scientists
studying it.
In order to avoid murky ethical issues, the
host was usually something inanimate like
a mannequin or a statue.
These conditions, however unsettling, allowed
the researchers to carry out interviews with
the consciousness housed inside the mask,
in the hope of beginning to understand it
and its motivations.
However, SCP-035 lost all access to its host
privileges after it almost pulled off an unprecedented,
shocking, and nearly catastrophic escape attempt.
In its early days at the facility, when it
was still allowed host privileges, it was
contained in a triple locked room and monitored
by several research personnel.
These were experienced researchers who had
been with the Foundation for a minimum of
five years each, an unusually long tenure
in such a dangerous and mentally corrosive
line of work.
These research staff members were thought
to be the most capable of handling interactions
with the mask, and be able to resist its attempts
at manipulation.
Unfortunately, these assumptions were naive,
and seriously underestimated the mask’s
power.
Research on the mask indicates that the mask
is incredibly intelligent and a skilled manipulator.
It has a photographic memory, intelligence
that would rank in the 99th percentile of
humans, and the ability to incite dramatic
changes in the behavior in people that it
talks to.
One particularly infamous interview, between
the entity and an unnamed Doctor at the Foundation,
suggested that the mask may even possess telepathic
abilities.
The mask was able to give details about the
Doctor’s life that no one else was privy
to, including knowledge of an affair that
his wife was having.
Following the interview, the Doctor suffered
a psychotic break and committed suicide just
24 hours later.
The mask is able to use its superior intelligence,
charismatic personality, and mind reading
abilities to get inside the heads of those
it speaks with.
It will pull out any and all psychological
stops to get what it wants, leaving broken
minds and spirits in its wake.
It was really only a matter of time before
it used this skill set to its advantage and
attempted to escape its confinement.
The day of the escape attempt was like any
other.
The research staff, a team of three intelligent,
experienced men, checked into the facility,
measured the conditions of the mask’s containment
unit, and began the process of interviewing
the mask like normal.
Its motions were slow and looked to require
great effort, as its current host was beginning
to degrade beyond use.
The mask was attached to the blank face of
a mannequin, and corrosive black liquid could
be seen oozing from its eye and mouth holes.
This liquid is excreted by the mask at a near-constant
rate, and is thought to be at least partially
responsible for the accelerated decay of the
host bodies.
In spite of the entity’s unsettling, nightmarish
appearance, it was just another day’s work
for the men assigned to monitor SCP-035, and
so they carried on with their daily routine.
Everything was going according to plan until
one of the men, Dr. Jones, began to behave
erratically.
He demanded that his fellow scientists leave
him alone with the mask for a while, and allow
him to engage in a private conversation with
it.
It is unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were absent,
as the security footage captured has no sound.
However, several minutes into the conversation
in the footage, Dr. Jones can be seen dissolving
into a fit of tears, laying on the ground
and shaking with sobs as the mask dispassionately
watches.
He then climbs onto his knees, begging the
mask for something, before he embraces it.
He holds the mannequin in his arms for five
straight minutes, weeping again, before they
separate.
After this disturbing emotional display, Dr.
Jones brought the other scientists back into
the room with him.
What happened next is still uncertain, but
there are a few things that we know for sure.
The other scientists began to speak with the
mask.
In later interviews, the other scientists
were bordering on incoherent, babbling about
various traumas from their lives.
One repeatedly referred to a drunk driving
accident where a dear friend was killed, and
he was at fault.
Another simply cried out for his mother again
and again.
Whatever the mask said to them, it was enough
to completely destroy their mental health.
After the other two scientists had been emotionally
devastated by the mask, Dr. Jones escalated
the situation further.
Dr. Jones removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body, and, shocking everyone who
would later review the security footage, placed
it onto his own face.
Once the mask was in place, Dr. Jones went
unnaturally still for several moments, as
his colleagues looked on.
This is where the security footage ends.
At the command of the mask which was now speaking
through Dr. Jones, the other two men switched
off all security cameras monitoring SCP-035’s
containment facility.
The mask, piloting the body of Dr. Jones like
a horrible fleshy puppet, made its way through
the facility, avoiding detection until it
reached the exit doors, where it was finally
stopped by a team of over a dozen security
guards.
Knowing the dangers of touching the mask,
all Foundation employees involved in the re-containment
of SCP-035 refused to remove it from Dr. Jones’
face.
Instead, he was placed in the locked room
with the mask still on, left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body had
decomposed beyond use.
His body paced back and forth in its cell
for days, flesh rotting and dropping away
until only sinew and bone remained.
Only when the bones began to turn black and
brittle, crumbling apart into dust, did the
body finally stop moving.
His family was notified, the mask was carefully
removed from what was left of his body, and
his remains were destroyed.
The other two scientists involved in the SCP-035
escape attempt were terminated, and their
files destroyed.
After this incident, a few more failed escape
attempts, and the acknowledgement of the devastation
that could have been caused if the mask had
made its way out into the general population,
SCP-035 lost its host privileges altogether.
Several research staff protested this decision,
insisting that there was more to be learned
from speaking with the entity, and citing
valuable information that it had given about
other SCP’s.
However, the risk was determined to considerably
outweigh the potential reward, and the request
to reinstate 035’s host privileges was denied.
Several staff members went so far as to erupt
into violent outbursts on 035’s behalf,
attacking their superiors who refused to provide
the mask with a new host, clawing at them
with animalistic rage.
Any staff members that submitted a request
to reinstate said privileges were considered
a security threat, and reassigned to a different
SCP or in some cases terminated.
Any staff member who had direct contact with
SCP-035 was also terminated, in order to avoid
the risk of any more staff-aided escape attempts.
The mask is now kept in a hermetically-sealed
glass case, and there is a psychologist on
call to provide assistance to anyone guarding
it, in case of adverse effects on their mental
health from the mask’s presence.
Personnel that work around the mask, even
in its current dormant state, experience frequent
violent outbursts and a higher rate of suicide.
Even without a host, the mask’s corrosive
effects have spread across its containment
facility.
The walls of the room have begun to secrete
the same black liquid that emanates from the
mask, which tests have revealed to be highly
contaminated human blood, that damages the
structural integrity of the walls following
prolonged contact.
This blood has begun to form patterns on the
walls, spelling out words and phrases in Italian,
Latin, Greek, and Sanskrit, as well as depicting
drawings of ritual sacrifice and mutilation.
Staff members also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying, high-pitched laughter
when in proximity to the mask.
Further exposure to the mask results in migraines,
hemorrhaging around the eyes, mouth, and nose,
and an eventual psychotic break.
Between the corrosive substance appearing
on the walls, and the physical and psychological
damage to employees, SCP-035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are debates
among staff as to whether the entity can,
in fact, be contained at all.
As soon as possible, SCP-035 will be moved
into a new containment facility, and its previous
cell will be isolated from the rest of the
foundation’s property and destroyed for
the safety of all involved.
We can only hope that the new containment
procedures are more effective than the last
ones, and that this mask never makes its way
into the world again.
If it does, who knows how many lives it will
claim?
In the meantime, if you ever come across a
strange mask and feel a nearly uncontrollable
urge to put it on…ignore the whispered pleas
to just try it, ignore the echoing laugher
and the sensation of something older and more
powerful than you can imagine rummaging through
your deepest, darkest secret thoughts.
Turn around, and run as fast as you can in
the other direction.
You’ll be glad that you did.
The desert is still.
The night seems endless, silent, and at peace…
until it’s pierced by the sound of gunshots
and screams.
Deep in the Sahara, the SCP Foundation is
waging war against a newly discovered enemy.
A squad of foundation agents is retreating,
trying to get away from the ones who massacred
their allies.
They were attempting to eliminate the threat
using conventional means, but their rifles
were no match for the reality bending entities
of the Kingdom of Abaddon.
The retreating agents cover one another as
they make their way back to the extraction
point.
The enemy force advances.
Agents that are caught too close to the sorcerers
of Abaddon disintegrate into thin air.
This is not an enemy they can defeat.
The SCP agents need to get back to base and
relay what they have found to their superiors.
Out of the hundreds of agents sent into the
Sahara that night, only a handful make it
out alive.
They are debriefed by their superiors at the
Foundation who classify the anomalous humanoids
under the highest of threat levels.
The Kingdom of Abaddon is a threat.
The Kingdom of Abaddon must be eliminated.
Reconnaissance done prior to the disastrous
mission had alerted the Foundation to the
presence of anomalies in the region, but they
had no idea how strong the anomalous humanoids
would be.
From data gathered through old reports, it
seemed that the Abaddon humanoids were responsible
for the deaths of no fewer than 75 Foundation
personnel, and had stolen at least 12 different
items from the Foundation.
The leaders of the SCP Foundation tasked research
team Omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the Kingdom
of Abaddon once and for all.
The weapon they are researching must be capable
of long range destruction, because the moment
any Foundation agent gets close to the area,
they are vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants The project is given
the name “Twins of God” and is led by
a Foundation doctor known only by the designation
“O5-1.”
O5-1 is popular in the SCP Foundation, well
known for his in-depth research and charismatic
personality, making him the perfect person
to lead such a project.
And O5-1 recently came across an anomaly that
he believes holds the solution the Foundation
has been looking for to defeat the Kingdom
of Abaddon…
Item-001.And so the Omega-5 team gets to work.
They discover that the anomaly has incredible
powers when put inside a host, which they
refer to as an Item-001 entity, and set up
a series of experiments using different people
to harness its energy The first series of
tests all end in tragedy.
The anomaly causes the entity it inhabits
to become intensely radioactive.
Anyone who gets close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness, and eventually death.
To stop the radiation problems the Omega-5
research group intensifies the containment
procedures.
O5-1 receives reports from the higher ups
that the Kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan.
Long-range defense is needed A.S.A.P.
The administrator puts more pressure on Omega-5,
and especially its leader O5-1, to solve the
problems of Item-001 and develop a weapon
that can save the Foundation.
He stays awake for days on end, working tirelessly
to create a safe and controllable Item-001
entity.
Although there are signs that the weapon will
work, it is still unpredictable.
When Item-001 is initiated, the host entity
becomes paralyzed, suffers severe cerebral
hemorrhaging, and soon a new host is needed
before testing can begin again.
And that’s not the only thing going wrong.
Whenever the anomaly is put into a new host,
sudden and random destruction of on-site structures
and personnel takes place.
O5-1 knows though, that if this power can
be harnessed and controlled in the right way,
that it could be the weapon that the Foundation
needs to wipe out the Kingdom of Abaddon once
and for all.
In order to control Item-001, O5-1 has a mind-kill
switch implanted in its hosts’ brains.
O5-1 can activate the implant to incapacitate
the host and immediately stop the unwanted
destruction.
Countless hosts are terminated by this mind-kill
switch in the early trials conducted by the
Omega-5 team, but progress continues to be
made and eventually a hypothesis is formulated.
Perhaps the disastrous side effects of Item-001
can be offset by spreading the anomaly across
multiple subjects.
They theorize that the immense mental load
of the anomaly can be distributed among several
hosts, thus reducing the toll it takes on
each and giving them the ability to control
its immense power.
But O5-1 and the Omega-5 team need more data,
and for that, they need more bodies.
They consult with the director of Site-17
and it is concluded that the nearby town of
San Marco would be an appropriate place to
get the additional test subjects they require.
On a quiet Sunday morning, Omega-5 along with
support from a squad of armed SCP agents storm
into the San Marcos de la Vida Sterna Church
during the middle of mass.
They gather up a number of the younger congregants
and bring them back to the site where Item-001
is housed.
The researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though, and Omega-5
would need to get even more if their research
was to continue.
Instead of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marco, O5-1 decides
to move the entire Item-001 operation to the
town itself.
He renames the town, Testing Site-001, and
Omega-5 rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series of
research tests.
A few weeks after occupying the town of San
Marco, Omega-5 makes it’s most substantial
progress yet.
Just as they theorized, by spreading out the
anomaly of Item-001 across a specific group
of hosts, they can control its powers.
The tests may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town, but the ends certainly
justify the means.
The Kingdom of Abaddon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all, and
thanks to this research they will soon have
a weapon capable of bringing them victory.
The Foundation administrator criticizes O5-1’s
methods, but can’t argue with his results.
Unfortunately, O5-1 has a dark secret.
A secret that disturbs even the most hardened
and loyal members of Omega-5.
A secret that has to do with the Item-001
hosts.
The hosts that Omega-5 has made its major
progress with are not the ordinary test subjects
normally used by the Foundation.
No, the test subjects O5-1 makes his breakthrough
with… are children.
Nine of them to be exact, all between four
and eleven years old.
Despite being told specifically by the Foundation
administrator to only test on adults, the
research required O5-1 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down the
path it led.
The children are contained in a reinforced
bunker where only O5-1, and a select few,
have access.
They are technically alive, but are functionally
brain dead.
The group of nine children share a hive mind
that can process information, and more importantly,
can unleash the full potential of the implanted
anomaly, creating and controlling a devastating
power.
But not everyone is thrilled with what they’ve
achieved.
Members of Omega-5 are haunted by the screams
of the children that they’ve forced to be
part of their weapon development program.
They describe their merging with Item-001
as being a process that rips out their souls
and replaces them with something much more
sinister.
In fact all of Omega-5 regret what they have
been a part of and what they’ve done, all
except O5-1.
The nine children can channel unprecedented
amounts of energy from an unknown origin that
Omega-5 hypothesizes comes from an extradimensional
source, which is then used to unbind atoms
at the quantum level.
When the right activation words are spoken,
it appears as though this tremendous power
gives the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe.
It’s the gun to end all guns.
And only O5-1 has the key to control it.
The nine children work so well within Item-001
that Omega-5 reclassifies it to include the
nine children themselves.
They are not just the entity housing or controlling
Item-001, they permanently become Item-001.
Once Omega-5 has a better understanding of
Item-001, they begin to run tests to find
out the full extent of its abilities.
First they test the distance Item-001 can
reach.
The initial test that Omega-5 carries out
is on a steel rod placed 5 kilometers away.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the target.
Moments later the phone next to O5-1 begins
to ring.
When he picks it up the observer tasked with
watching the pole is on the other end.
He informs O5-1 that the steel rod has been
completely vaporized.
O5-1 is not satisfied though.
He has another pole set out, this time placed
8,000 kilometers away from the nine children.
O5-1 asks the children to destroy that rod.
Almost immediately, the phone rings again.
The target has been vaporized.
O5-1 smiles.
The next series of tests Omega-5 runs on Item-001
are to determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed.
The tests start out with a steel sphere, 3
meters in diameter, placed 1,000 kilometers
from Item-001.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the object.
It is instantly vaporized.
O5-1 has seen enough small tests.
It’s time for something big.
So he does something that will later be questioned
by everyone at the SCP Foundation.
He orders the nine children to destroy a Church
of the Broken God worship site in Turkey.
Not long after the destruction order is given
to Item-001, reports begin coming in.
The worship site has been obliterated with
no observable damage to the surrounding area.
Deadly and precise.
O5-1 closes his eyes and takes a deep breath.
He looks as if he is overcome by an immense
spiritual experience.
He opens his eyes, leans over to the children,
and whispers the name of someone.
Later that day, O5-1 finds out that the target
he had named has been vaporized.
The success of Omega-5 and Item-001 is relayed
to the administration of the Foundation.
They are so impressed that they make plans
to use Item-001 to eliminate the Abaddon threat
once and for all.
However, one of the heads of the foundation,
Administrator Williams, has major concerns
about the way O5-1 is running the program.
The updates that O5-1 has been sending have
become less scientific, and more philosophical…
more…
spiritual.
Administrator Williams sends a letter to O5-1
reassuring him that he is doing good work,
but once the mission to destroy the Kingdom
of Abaddon is completed, O5-1 will be promoted
to director, and reassigned to the newly constructed
Site-19.
For the good of the Foundation, and maybe
the world, he’ll be permanently moved away
from Item-001.
O5-1’s response is short and to the point,
“I am fine, Administrator.
The project is finished.
We will complete our task when you arrive.”
Administrator Williams arrives at Site-001
a few days later.
He is greeted by O5-1 and the Omega-5 team.
Williams can’t help but notice that O5-1
has a strange look in his eyes.
It is the look of a crazed man who has been
lost in his work, and who has, perhaps, lost
himself.
Williams puts the thought away though and
walks with O5-1 and his accompanying agents
to the viewing area where the powers of Item-001
will be demonstrated.
Administrator Williams and the other agents
watch from a protected viewing room as O5-1
enters the chamber of his new super weapon.
It’s time to see if their weapon that has
had so much time, effort, sweat, tears, and
especially blood poured into it, will have
been worth it.
Everyone watches as O5-1 leans over and says
the name of the Abaddon Citadel to the nine
children.
All at once, they start to glow.
No one observing can see what has happened
in the far off Kingdom, but they know something
big has happened.
The administrator is thrilled, but notices
something.
O5-1 hesitated a moment while leaning over
the children before standing back up.
Did he whisper something else to them?
And then Administrator Williams vaporizes,
pulled apart at an atomic level before he
has the chance to scream.
What’s going on?
The agents standing next to where Administrator
Williams previously existed begin to yell
and pull out their guns.
They burst through the door of the observation
room and run down the hallway towards where
O5-1 and the nine children are located.
The armed agents rush into the room, but O5-1
is gone.
The nine children are still.
Over the next few weeks O5-1 is reported to
be seen several times by SCP agents.
However, no one is able to catch him, and
it appears as though other members of the
SCP Foundation have also gone AWOL as well,
perhaps joining him on the run.
It is unclear what his plan is, but reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into the
Sahara make it obvious what the result of
his first command to the children was.
There isn’t a single humanoid or building
left in the Kingdom of Abaddon.
But even with this victory, the highest levels
of the SCP Foundation have an ominous thought
lurking in the back of their minds.
Where did O5-1 go, and what is he planning
to do next?
Following the improper use of Item-001 leading
to the untimely death of a high ranking Foundation
Staff member, the weapon was deemed too dangerous
and containment procedures were implemented.
Due to the high amount of radiation they were
found to emit, the nine children were placed
into lead lined bags and buried under 50 meters
of concrete beneath the church of San Marcos
de la Vida Eterna.
Though all of the children continue to be
functionally braindead, they still display
signs of life despite their containment, and
by order of the Overseer Council, have been
classified as a Thaumiel entity.
It’s a natural instinct in many species
to protect their young - and sometimes it's
not just their own babies, but any young that
look like them.
Regardless of your personal feelings on human’s
earliest stage, it is a scientific fact that
human babies are designed to emphasize their
own adorable helplessness to make sure that
other, older humans take care of them.
A baby’s cry is an inherently distressing
sound, and when we hear it, some deep, primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and care
for the child until the sound stops.
But of course, we’re talking about the world
of the SCP Foundation here - where there are
bunnies that can eat anything, teddy bears
that might steal your organs to make duplicates
of themselves, and chocolate fountains filled
with trillions of murderous insects.
Nothing is what it seems here, and even the
most innocent and cute creatures may be hiding
a deadly secret - SCP-734 being no exception.
Today, we’re talking about The Baby.
This anomaly proves that dangerous things
can come in small packages, but where others
only saw misery and death, the SCP Foundation
saw a certain potential…
Our story begins in the maternity ward of
a hospital in the USA, where every medical
professional’s worst nightmare was unfolding:
An unknown but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogen seemed to be running rampant across
the hospital’s population.
It began when patients who weren’t even
admitted for dermatological issues started
complaining of severe itches and extreme skin
pain.
Some nurses and doctors in the maternity ward
began to experience similar symptoms, as well
as one of the infants, leading to a massive
quarantine effort.
While the initial symptoms first appeared
to be limited to severe pain and discomfort
on isolated parts of the skin, the condition
of the afflicted soon escalated.
Their skin began to messily flake off as the
cells comprising it lost physical cohesion
and died.
It was a kind of strange, anomalous rot that
seemed to work inwards, first destroying the
integrity of the outer layer of skin and then
causing further disintegration to deeper parts
of the body.
Once the skin had shed off, the pathogen would
turn its attention to what was lying beneath.
Against all odds, the disease affected organs,
muscle tissue, the vascular system, and even
bones.
Nothing was spared.
The victims’ bodies would completely break
down, and they would be dead within a few
hours.
By the time the pathogen had finished ravaging
its victims, what was left didn’t even look
human anymore.
Not only patients but doctors and nurses that
had been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human tissue
sitting in what had previously been their
hospital beds.
Whatever this was, it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded history.
Hospital staff and administrators were terrified
- this appeared to be an entirely new disease,
with a mysterious form of transmission and,
worst of all, no cure.
They were even more confused when several
black vans pulled up outside the hospital,
and mysterious men in hazmat suits spilled
out and began setting up a quarantine zone
around the entire building.
Whoever these strange people were, they definitely
weren’t the CDC - little did the hospital
personnel know that this was the group you
never want showing up and putting your location
on lockdown - it was the SCP Foundation.
The infected remains of the victims were taken
away for research purposes, and the Foundation
operatives immediately began conducting debriefing
interviews with witnesses.
They soon determined from a mix of eyewitness
accounts and hospital surveillance footage
that everyone infected with the mysterious
pathogen had all been in a particular section
of the maternity ward earlier in the day.
And when the operatives investigated this
area, they found another strange detail.
An infant had no registered mother present
in the hospital.
The Foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby’s mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease.
After eliminating all other possible options,
it seemed that the only anomalous element
that could have caused all of this was the
mysterious baby, though just how the mother
even survived carrying the baby to term was
a mystery in and of itself.
The baby was a caucasian male human infant
between seven and eight months of age.
Nothing appeared outwardly anomalous about
the child, but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the child
earlier that day.
Everyone who had been at the hospital was
given amnestic treatment, and the Foundation
constructed plausible cover stories for the
deaths that had occurred that day.
Like so many others before it, the child was
secured and spirited away to the nearest applicable
Foundation containment site.
There it was reclassified as SCP-734, and
finally the real testing into what precisely
this infant was capable of could begin.
Physiologically, SCP-734 appeared mostly non-anomalous.
The infant had above-average intelligence
and physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or abnormalities
that would suggest a divergence from typical
human biology.
Despite a vast array of tests performed by
the Foundation into essentially every aspect
of 734’s biology, they couldn’t find anything
that hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen.
But through some trial and extremely costly
error, the Foundation was able to learn more
about how exactly the pathogen worked.
The only vector for transmission seemed to
be direct contact with the baby itself, up
to and including the fluids and residues it
leaves behind.
Those affected cannot transmit the anomalous
“flaking” effect to others, meaning that
the risk of an epidemic is relievingly minimal.
But of course, accidents still happen, as
was discovered when one agent misplaced her
sympathy for the baby and decided to remove
her mask while interacting with him.
Her logic was that her masked face might have
caused the baby some kind of distress, and
as long as she was only coming into contact
with him via her own gloved hands, everything
would be fine.
But some dust particles were floating in the
air at the time, and SCP-734 sneezed in her
face.
The agent began screaming in pain and recoiling
from the baby, but it was already too late.
Her fate was sealed.
She was taken to the infirmary and given sedatives
so that she could hopefully die in as little
pain as possible.
In roughly 72% of cases, amputation of the
affected areas has prevented the entire body
from succumbing to the anomalous effects of
SCP-734, but this isn’t exactly feasible
when the point of contact is the victim’s
head.
Within hours, the agent’s flesh had flaked
off of her face, leaving her looking like
a red, bloody skull.
A few hours after that, she didn’t have
a head at all.
Throughout the disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent, the Foundation took grisly
photographs.
These photographs are shown to anyone preparing
to work on the SCP-734 research project to
teach them a hard lesson on the importance
of adhering to proper safety protocols.
And these protocols about how to deal with
the Baby are incredibly tight, given that
even incidental contact is often a death sentence.
Anyone entering the Baby’s containment chamber
needs to wear contained-atmosphere hazmat
suits.
Anyone who makes physical contact with the
Baby, even when suited up, is immediately
removed from the area and subject to several
hours of quarantine and observation.
Even inanimate objects that have been inside
the containment chamber need to be thoroughly
sterilized before being removed.
Given that even anomalous children like SCP-734
have very delicate needs, a handler is always
standing by in full hazmat gear to take care
of the baby.
These handlers are rotated every hour to maintain
alertness and safety.
These handlers feed and change SCP-734 regularly
and sometimes even provide toys that have
been approved by the O5 Council.
The Foundation has gone to great lengths to
keep SCP-734 alive and comfortable because
they believe that SCP-734 could be an important
asset for them in the future.
Or, more specifically, they see great strategic
value in SCP-734’s blood.
As mentioned earlier, contact with any matter
from SCP-734 triggers its deadly anomalous
effects, including bodily fluids like blood.
But, unlike many toxic pathogens, in this
case there is no risk of the infection getting
out of control since the infected do not become
vectors for transmission.
Because of this, the blood of SCP-734 can
act as a powerful weapon for both terminating
anomalies deemed unviable by the O5 Council
and assassinating dangerous people who belong
to rival groups.
Contact with the blood would completely destroy
the target’s body, with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly conducted
the hit.
SCP-734 has been fitted with an arterial catheter
so that the Foundation can collect large quantities
of blood from the anomalous infant every single
week for storage and research.
But it isn’t just the blood that the Foundation
sees potential in.
SCP-734 himself has scored incredibly well
on the Aeslinger Loyalty Index, the test the
Foundation uses to judge the loyalty of potential
applicants to the Foundation cause.
As SCP-734 matures, if these scores remain
consistent, he will likely be trained to become
a Foundation field agent in the future.
An agent capable of killing someone with a
touch would, needless to say, be an asset
to certain covert missions that the Foundation
would probably prefer to keep off the books.
Of course, the SCP Foundation recruiting certain
compliant anomalies to perform missions for
them is far from unprecedented.
The most infamous of these is SCP-076, also
known as Able, a supernatural, eternally-resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest warriors
who ever lived.
The Foundation took note of this and channeled
his eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own Mobile Task Force.
He could assist in missions by taking out
his bloodlust on enemy groups of interest
and dangerous anomalies.
However, this ended up working a little too
well and led to disaster.
Able was so good at his job that he burned
through all his allotted missions at astonishing
speed.
Left with nothing more to do, Able got antsy,
which led to him turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the Foundation
as a whole.
It was an all-out massacre before his colleagues
were finally able to kill him and return him
to containment.
The failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the Foundation
in the field a bad name.
But since then, things have changed, especially
with the establishment of MTF Alpha-9, aka
Last Hope, a new mobile task force formed
entirely of anomalous individuals and their
handlers.
These consist of somewhat more stable anomalies,
such as Able’s counterpart, SCP-073, also
known as Cain.
Cain cannot be harmed, with any harm befalling
him simply being mirrored back on his attacker,
and his vast array of knowledge makes him
an incredibly useful intelligence asset.
Another of the several members of Last Hope
is Iris, also known as SCP-105.
Much like Cain, Iris not only has anomalous
powers that make her immensely valuable for
missions in the field, she’s also compliant
and capable of listening to reason, unlike
Cain.
Her abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of any
location, especially when taken with her anomalous
camera.
Someday, SCP-734 could count himself among
other anomalous Foundation agents like these,
providing he continues to show promise and
doesn’t develop a dislike of the Foundation
as he ages, since after all, he won’t be
a baby forever.
So if ever you find yourself on the Foundation’s
bad side, you have a good reason to be paranoid.
You’ll have no idea that one day, the man
who’s going to kill you will approach and
shake your hand with a smile.
It won’t be until later when you feel that
strange tingle on your palm and feel the skin
starting to flake away that you’ll realize
you’ve been a dead man walking for hours.
“There’s an app for that!”
It was a phrase so ubiquitous in the early
days of the smartphone craze that it’s hard
to believe Apple actually has it trademarked.
It was a testament to a simple and immutable
truth about the world these new touchscreen
phones were creating: No matter how strange
and obscure the need, there would be an app
to fulfill it.
Perhaps you remember iBeer - The app that
allowed you to pretend you were drinking a
tall glass of beer…
For some reason.
There was Carrr Matey, an app that reminded
you where you parked your car…
In a pirate voice.
And who could forget “I Am Bread”, a surreal
game about controlling a sentient slice of
bread on a quest to become toast.
But there’s one app out there somewhere
on the market that you probably didn’t download.
And if you did, well, you have our sincerest
apologies, because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a chill
down your spine - Well, if that chill ever
even left.
Take it from one gentleman whose life took
a very strange turn after downloading a certain
app that the SCP Foundation calls SCP-1471.
Because the sentiment “There’s an app
for that” doesn’t exclude experiencing
mortal terror…
Joe Lillis, an insurance salesman from Milwaukee,
had just gone through another atrocious date.
After a mediocre meal and an uncomfortable
35 minutes of inane babble, sensing the whole
time that she really wasn’t that interested,
his date excused herself to take a quick phone
call outside.
Sadly for Joe, she never returned, leaving
him to pick up the check.
Of all the many words you could use to describe
poor Joe Lillis, the most pertinent would
be “lonely.”
Ever since Carol, his wife of ten years, had
passed away in a freak accident, he’d been
trying to find some kind of way to fill the
void.
They’d been high school sweethearts, intent
on spending the rest of their lives with one
another.
As fate would have it, only Carol would get
that tainted luxury.
Joe would be forced to endure life after the
joy of living had run its course.
He only hoped he might be lucky enough to
find love again.
However, Joe was on the wrong side of forty,
and as so many others his age were already
hitched, he could feel his options going out
one by one.
Would he be destined to live out the rest
of his days alone?
Joe didn’t feel like spending the back half
of his life catching reruns of Seinfeld and
tending to his fish; he needed to get out
of there.
And thankfully, like the rest of us, he lived
in the internet age - He had more apps, websites,
online services, and hot russian singles in
his area than he knew what to do with.
So, surely, one would have the right person
for him!
He’d tried them all: Tinder, Hinge, Match.com,
Plenty of Fish, eHarmony, Bumble, Zoosk, OKCupid,
Friend Finder, Deeply Lonely Singles with
Low Expectations.com, and so much more.
However, all it seemed to achieve was setting
him up for more disappointment.
None of the dates he’d managed to get ever
resulted in anything getting serious.
Heck, it was a minor miracle if he managed
to get any of them on a second date.
Was this it?
Was this his life now?
Had he only ever gotten one shot at love,
and the grasping claws of fate yanked it away
from him without a second thought?
Would life continue on the hamster wheel of
loneliness - sleeping, getting up, eating,
working, and sleeping again, every day getting
somehow both faster and slower as life trudged
on to a disappointing yet inevitable conclusion?
What a terrible fate to find yourself trapped
in…
Whenever Joe started feeling maudlin like
this, he knew it was time to get proactive
again.
Maybe the right woman was out there - there
were billions of them, after all, surely at
least one of them would be the perfect person
for him.
He just needed the perfect app…
He’d burned through all the most reputable
apps already, and was now perusing some of
the slightly seedier options - most of which
were likely data mining fronts from the Balkans.
However, as generic app after generic app
passed, something different caught his eye.
The icon was a smiling cartoon dog, and its
name was MalO Version.
1.0.0.
This gave him a little chuckle.
At the very least, it was very different branding
from the rest of the dating apps he’d seen.
Maybe it’d just been sorted into the wrong
section of the app store?
He decided he’d click it and take a look
at the app’s description.
The description read:
“Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!”
Well…
It certainly provoked Joe’s curiosity, at
the very least.
He did want to banish his feelings of loneliness,
and seeing as the app was free and apparently
had no ads, he’d surely be foolish to not
at least give it a whirl.
What’s the worst that could happen?
He began the installation and only then noticed
that the app had no listed developer.
It took up 9.8 MB of memory, which he wasn’t
tech savvy enough to see any issues with.
More than anything, Joe was just enticed by
the prospect of finally having another chance
at companionship with MalO.
After all, it is the “next social substitute”,
whatever that means.
However, Joe’s excitement was quickly quashed
when he hit the home screen button, and noticed
that the icon for the app never actually materialized.
Strange.
He checked the app store portal again and
saw that, according to them, the app had completely
downloaded.
What gives?
Was it a glitch, or was MalO actually just
malware?
Either way, he was disheartened by the fact
that this immaterial app certainly wouldn’t
be getting him any companionship.
Or so he thought, anyway.
Joe was used to disappointment by now, so
he didn’t take the hit too personally.
He decided to just play out the rest of his
evening on autopilot: Making himself some
soup, doing the laundry, watching more Seinfeld
reruns, taking a cold shower, and preparing
to cry himself to sleep again.
MalO was already becoming a distant memory,
just like all deceptive sources of hope.
But one strange thing happened that disrupted
Joe’s finely-tuned evening routine.
He received a text message.
This was incredibly strange, because nobody
ever seemed to text him.
The last text he got was from Carol, just
before her accident, so it was almost surreal
to hear that alert sound now, after everything
that’d happened.
He checked and saw that the text was an image
attachment sent from an unknown number.
Perplexed yet curious, he decided to open
it.
His curiosity soon gave way to a kind of melancholy
nostalgia when he saw that the photo was of
his and Carol’s favorite cafe in town.
They’d spent many a morning there, back
when she was alive.
Treating themselves to a nice cup of coffee
and perhaps a croissant.
Just seeing it again caused an involuntary
smile to spread across his face.
It never even occurred to him, as it probably
would have to others, that this could be seen
as a little creepy.
He hadn’t frequented the bakery since Carol
died.
How would anyone even know that the place
held any significance for him?
Was it a stalker?
A ghost?
Or just a spooky coincidence?
None of these thoughts even crossed Joe’s
mind.
He was just grateful for the surprising reminder
of the happiness he’d once had.
For the next couple hours, things seemed…
Lighter.
He went about his evening, checking the photo
every so often and smiling, until eventually
he found himself in bed, still looking into
the glow of his phone.
It was such a beautiful little cafe…
Then, he froze.
He noticed something in the picture.
It’d been there the whole time, but only
now was he seeing rather than just looking.
It was in the corner, staring through the
glass of the cafe’s door.
So faint he almost wanted to dismiss it as
a trick of the light.
It was a face - Well, not a face, more like
a skull.
Not human, not anywhere near human.
Long, slender, and canine, with protruding
fangs and vacant white eyes.
The pure white of the skull was buried in
a nest of thick, black hair.
It looked like it was crouching behind the
door, looking out, and grinning, whatever
the hell it was.
Just seeing it changed the entire tone of
the picture.
It was no longer a simple reminder of bygone
joy.
Now, all that was radiating out of that image
was a palpable sense of dread.
Was someone playing some kind of awful prank
on him?
Just then, he was jogged from his contemplation
by another alert.
A new message from the same number as before.
With great hesitation, he hovered his thumb
over the push notification and clicked.
That’s when everything got a lot worse.
It was a photo of a bus stop.
Not just any bus stop, of course, it was Stop
C16 - The one that Joe always took to get
to work.
It looked like it was taken relatively early
in the morning, but nobody was there.
Well…
Not quite nobody.
There was that figure again.
It stood at full height, behind the partially
frosted glass that makes up the back of the
bus stop.
That same large, black humanoid shape, with
a white, grinning dog skull where the face
should be.
Something about it terrified him on such a
primal level, like the way our lizard brain
reacts to some ancient apex predator.
And whatever this thing was, it clearly knew
something about him.
How else could it stage all these photos?
Joe got out of bed and looked out the window,
down onto his dark front street.
Empty, thankfully, but after this surprise
nightmare, he wasn’t going to take any chances.
He grabbed a kitchen knife from downstairs
and placed it on his bedside cabinet, right
next to his phone, with 911 on speed dial.
Joe Lillis, a 43 year old man, slept with
the lights on that night for the first time
in over thirty years.
Sadly for him, the nightmare was just beginning.
The next morning, Joe woke up unharmed, but
he wasn’t pleased to see that he’d gotten
several more texts in his sleep.
There was one taken outside of the local insurance
company office where he worked.
The strange creature with the skull for a
face was looming around the corner, peering
at the camera with its lipless grin.
Like it was mocking him.
Another photo was taken at the local supermarket
where Joe did most of his grocery shopping.
The frame was centralized on the cereal aisle,
bordered on both sides by walls of garish
mascots, endlessly repeated.
Down at the far end of the aisle was a looming,
dark figure, with that cold, canine skull
where a human face should be.
There were a few more, but worst of all was
the last one.
It was taken at the cemetery.
In the foreground, a headstone, reading “Carol
Lillis - Beloved Wife and Daughter.”
Joe was horrified to see that skull-faced
beast was rising up behind his wife’s grave,
long, clawed fingers curling around the top
of the headstone.
That was the moment that Joe decided to go
to the police about all this, before things
got even more out of hand.
He called an Uber to get down to the station
- He certainly didn’t feel like going anywhere
near his regular bus stop after last night.
He showed the photos he’d been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station, and they
agreed that there was certainly something
strange about it.
While the behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment, it hadn’t yet delved into criminal
territory, so he would sadly be on his own
until then.
The best they could do was stay in touch and
keep abreast of any new developments.
The only sage advice they could give him was
not to delete the photos, as they could always
be used as evidence in court later if things
escalated.
This was literally the last result that Joe
wanted out of this.
Considering how bizarre and threatening things
were getting already, he really didn’t want
to find out what escalation looked like in
this case.
But what else could he do but carry on, just
trying to exercise as much caution as he could
in these strange new circumstances?
He went to work and tried his best to stay
productive, despite the fact that every three
or so hours, a new photo would arrive.
Places that he liked to sit in the local parks,
stores he’d frequent, restaurants he liked
to eat at.
That nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them, just mugging for
the camera.
On one hand, every time he looked at one of
the photos, Joe felt like he was giving this
freak exactly what they wanted.
On the other hand, how could he possibly look
away?
What if he missed something that could save
his life?
It carried on much like that until later in
the evening.
Joe may not have been a genius, but he was
no fool, either.
He’d seen too many of those seedy True Crime
documentaries about kidnapping to take his
normal route home.
He took a real detour, frequently checking
over his shoulder the entire time.
Much to his relief, he didn’t see anything
out of place.
Good.
When he got home, he locked every door and
bolted every window.
Nothing would be getting the jump on him tonight.
That’s when the next picture came in: A
photograph of Joe’s empty office cubicle,
with the bony face of the creature looming
over the divider with a grin.
He could feel his heart pounding away in his
chest just looking at it.
How did this thing get around like this?
How was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life?
Suddenly, he felt a smile spreading across
his face.
This freak had just messed up, big time.
Before, all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places.
But the one taken in his office?
Oh, this crossed the line into trespassing.
The police would have to do something about
it now.
It’d given him an ace up his sleeve.
That confidence faded a few hours later when
he received another photo: This time, it was
the skull-faced monster just standing on the
sidewalk - The sidewalk that Joe remembered
walking on his “covert” alternative route.
He felt himself break into a cold sweat.
It seemed, whoever this was, he really did
hold no secrets from them.
Now more than ever, Joe didn’t feel safe
in his own home.
So you can only imagine how he felt when,
a few hours later, he received a photo of
the skull-faced stalker standing right outside
his own front door, staring into the camera.
It sent him rushing to the window again to
check outside, but of course, nobody was there.
The next day, when he called the police and
updated them on the situation, they told him
that they were doing all they could.
The best thing he could possibly do was to
remain calm, but vigilant.
He needed to keep an eye on the photos being
sent to him, so he could notify them if ever
he was in any immediate danger.
This put poor Joe’s paranoia at a fever
pitch.
Even when he went to work, surrounded by coworkers,
by witnesses, he could scarcely tear his eyes
away from his phone.
He was a slave to the photos, forever waiting
for the next one.
Only to experience crushing regret when that
photo actually arrived.
It looked like it was taken moments before
it was sent to him.
Joe saw himself, looking at his own phone
in his office cubicle, with that huge, skull-faced
figure looming behind him.
He screamed out loud upon seeing it, and turned
to see if anything was behind him.
But of course, there was nothing there.
The police inspected the office, talked to
potential witnesses, and analyzed the photo.
It showed no signs of any photographic manipulation,
but there were also no witnesses around the
office who claimed to see anything strange
that day.
There was also no security camera footage
in the last several days that showed this
figure coming in or out.
Joe Lillis started to feel like he was going
insane, and perhaps he was, but that didn’t
change the tangible and ever-present feeling
that he was in great danger.
He didn’t come into work the next day.
He’d received more photos like that in the
night: Of himself, taken in real time, with
that skull-faced freak looming.
He didn’t want to leave the house.
He didn’t want to go anywhere anymore.
He just didn’t feel safe out there.
How could he, with all this madness unfolding?
There was a time when he could have said something
like, “At least it only seems confined to
my phone”, he might’ve even suspected
that it had something to do with that strange
MalO app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn’t seemed to do anything.
But the situation had evolved since then.
He wasn’t just seeing the creature in photos
anymore.
It was here.
He kept seeing quick flashes of it on the
other side of windows.
In reflections.
In the corner of his eyes, always darting
away if ever he turned towards it.
It was everywhere and nowhere.
It was here for him.
He just knew it.
The police couldn’t help.
Nobody could help.
Joe just sat in the corner of his bedroom,
clutching his kitchen knife, afraid to close
his eyes.
It could be anywhere.
It could be anywhere…
We know one thing for sure: Joe Lillis never
felt truly alone ever again.
He always had his new friend, waiting, just
out of sight.
And if ever you’re feeling lonesome, and
decide to download Mal0 version 1.0.0 yourself,
then you’ll never feel lonely again, either…
If you have ever taken a trip to Suntop Mountain
in the Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest,
Washington State, then you may have come across
an old wooden structure - The Suntop Fire
Lookout.
Built in the early 1930s, the building was
used by the US Forest Service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby woodland.
At one point, Suntop Fire Lookout would have
been manned 365 days a year, complete with
a bed for staff who were stationed there on
rotation.
The single story lookout house overlooks the
scenic valleys of the White River and Huckleberry
Creek, but you’re not here for an informative
tourist guide.
You probably don’t care about the frankly
fascinating history of the lookout and how
it was used as part of the Aircraft Warning
Service during World War 2, watching for enemy
planes.
No, you’re here because something much darker
lurks inside the Suntop Fire Lookout.
And even though it appears to be a simple,
one-story-tall wooden structure, it certainly
is not short on space.
SCP-3333 refers to an anomaly that the Foundation
discovered inside the Suntop Fire Lookout
house.
The building’s interior is a single, square
room, measuring fourteen feet by fourteen
feet, with large windows on all four sides.
When standing inside Suntop Fire Lookout,
looking up at the wooden ceiling, one will
immediately notice a trapdoor.
No big deal, right?
A lot of places have a ceiling entrance to
a small crawl space, there is probably nothing
behind the trapdoor, apart from a dusty, old
attic.
There’s a latch that maybe once had a padlock
there, but not anymore.
Opening the trapdoor will reveal a collapsible
ladder.
Should anyone be brave, or indeed foolish
enough, to begin to climb, then they’ll
soon find themselves right back where they
started, inside Suntop Fire Lookout.
Or so it will seem.
The thing about being in a place like the
Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest that
surrounds Suntop Fire Lookout is that woodland
areas are teeming with life.
Not just plants and trees, but birds and other
animals of the forest.
You can never truly be alone in a setting
like that, there is always life everywhere
around you.
So, when you ascend the ladder, and climb
out right back into the Suntop Fire Lookout,
that is the first, most noticeable difference
you will find.
It may take a while at first, but the nagging
absence of something usually so abundant in
a forest will eventually become obvious.
It’s quiet, far too quiet.
No birdsong, or the sound of distant calls
from woodland critters.
Just silence, all around.
Anyone ascending the ladder will find themselves
in a copy of Suntop Fire Lookout’s interior,
one story higher than the ground level of
the small wooden building, with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting taller
each time to reach up to the higher and higher
building.
Now, you know the SCP Foundation and the types
of bizarre, inter dimensional anomalies they’re
used to dealing with.
Perhaps SCP-3333 is a mirror dimension, or
a plane of existence where sound doesn’t
travel.
It certainly seems to be identical to the
Suntop Fire Lookout, save for the lack of
any organic life outside.
Of course, it’s what you’ll find living
inside SCP-3333 that you may want to worry
about.
Climbing higher, up the next ladder and through
the next trapdoor, every time with the same
result.
You appear at another copy of Suntop Fire
Lookout, each one higher up than the last.
What first seemed to be an innocuous, unassuming
wooden building is now an endless ascension
up into the heavens, towards the unknown in
silence, without a shred of plant or animal
life outside.
As you climb, perhaps you start to think how
much higher these copies go.
This might even be the biblical Jacob’s
Ladder, connecting Heaven and Earth.
That would be nice, wouldn’t it?
If you were gradually climbing your way up
to paradise, it might make it worth the trip.
But SCP-3333 is nothing that pleasant.
You wouldn’t be the first to attempt this
long climb.
When the SCP Foundation first discovered SCP-3333,
a research detail set up an onsite base camp
to examine this spatial anomaly.
Their first exploration involved sending a
member of D-class personnel, designated D-4f68a,
up the ladder.
His D-number is a hexadecimal code that, when
translated to text, reads ‘Oh’, so we’ll
call him that for brevity’s sake.
During the first day’s exploration, Oh was
able to climb 184 iterations of SCP-3333,
communicating with head researcher Doctor
Williams below.
On the second day, Oh could see a pair of
figures standing motionless on a nearby ridge,
but the pair could not be seen by Doctor Williams
and the other researchers at the base camp.
Both figures disappeared shortly after Oh
spotted them with the camera he had been issued,
and he felt uneasy, almost certain that he
saw them point at him.
The next day, at the 345th copy of Suntop
Fire Lookout, Oh’s behavior started to noticeably
change.
Previously, he had been anxious about the
long climb, and hadn’t questioned directions
given to him by Doctor Williams.
Now, he seemed to speak more casually, resisting
instructions, asking Williams to climb back
down and even calling her ‘Doc’ instead
of ‘Doctor’.
Oh also reported seeing writing on the walls,
but there was no evidence of this on his camera.
It appeared that something had started to
affect him.
It was when Oh reached level 527 that things
seemed to change more dramatically.
Rather than SCP-3333 continuing upwards, the
copies of Suntop Fire Lookout no longer had
a trapdoor or ladder.
They seemed to be arranged side by side, in
a grid-like pattern.
Stepping out of the main doorway, Oh remarked
on the lack of sunlight, and a walkway that
connected directly to the front door of the
next iteration of SCP-3333.
Oh complained about the lack of natural light,
and again requested to be allowed back down.
Doctor Williams instructed Oh to use the flashlights
he was provided, but they wouldn’t activate
and their spare batteries had vanished.
Oh then noticed a sudden movement, and just
then his microphone and camera feed went dead,
almost as if someone had turned them off.
It appeared that SCP-3333 had something else
lurking up there.
Doctor Williams oversaw the second expedition
into SCP-3333.
This time members of Mobile Task Force Mod-0,
also known by the codename “Characteristic
Eigenspaces”, were sent up the ladder.
Their ascent through the various copies of
Suntop Fire Lookout were not as eventful as
Oh’s, with no signs of mysterious figures,
or anxious feelings that Oh seemed to feel
as he climbed.
When they reached level 527, where the copies
of the lookout stop progressing upwards and
spread out in a pattern instead, their lights
and equipment all seemed to be in working
order.
However, as the MTF team split up, one by
one they encountered some sort of anomaly,
or an effect of SCP-3333 that caused each
of them to vanish into the dark.
Either that, or something took them.
These MTF units reappeared confused, and Mod-5,
the team’s leader, Graham Purcell, issued
an order to retreat and the entire squad went
back down the ladders for several days until
they finally reached the base camp again.
The members of Mod-0 were adamant they did
not wish to climb SCP-3333 again, but Doctor
Williams was beginning to understand more
of the anomaly’s effects.
It appeared to cause abrupt changes to people’s
personalities, along with some sort of phenomenon
that caused things to appear and disappear
the higher one climbed.
Assuming these were the results of a memetic
effect, Doctor Williams dispatched a ‘counter
memetics specialist’ for the next expedition.
This specialist was a blind, deaf, and mute
woman known as Annette or the ‘Nullwalker’,
who communicated via a signaling system embedded
in her hand, but was otherwise immune to any
memetic influences.
Observed by Doctor Williams and Graham Purcell
at base camp, Annette made her way to the
top of SCP-3333, reporting that she was aware
of someone watching her from outside the copies
of Suntop Fire Lookout.
On her body camera, a flicker of motion occurred,
something looking through the windows that
ducked out of frame when the camera passed
in its direction.
At the apex of SCP-3333, Annette kept her
flashlight off, but reported that she could
detect blood, following it to what she assumed
was a body.
Sounds of movement surrounded her, and as
Annette switched on her flashlight, Williams
and Purcell saw that it wasn’t a body in
front of her.
Instead, it was a pile of rotting organs,
decomposing muscles and discarded bones.
And among the pile was a metal dog tag, that
read ‘MTF Mod-5: Graham Purcell’; the
same man who was sitting next to Doctor Williams
at base camp.
Well, the same man on the outside at least.
The explanation for everything going on inside
SCP-3333, all these strange occurrences and
disappearances, finally came in a video sent
from Doctor Williams’ cell phone.
In it, a panicked Williams, covered in blood,
was fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of SCP-3333.
There was no memetic effect at the apex of
the Suntop Fire Lookout copies.
Nothing was causing the people that the Foundation
sent up to act unlike themselves.
They simply weren’t themselves anymore.
According to her frantic video, Doctor Williams
had discovered the truth about what else was
hiding within SCP-3333.
With just the right amount of vagueness and
intrigue, the research team had been drawn
in.
It was as if they’d been lured in by the
lights of an anglerfish, realizing their grim
fate only too late.
The D-class ‘Oh’, the MTF team, even Annette
had been replaced.
An unknown group of entities on the top level
of SCP-3333 had been carefully observing them,
waiting until they would not be seen to slip
in and switch places.
These entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects, like Oh seeing figures
that weren’t really there, as a way of luring
more bodies further up the stack.
They wanted the Foundation to keep sending
expeditions into SCP-3333, to keep them coming
back.
The mass of organs, musculature, and bones
that Annette had stumbled across, revealing
the ruse, had once belonged to Graham Purcell,
before he was replaced.
You see, the entities residing in SCP-3333
weren’t just copying people.
They weren’t possessing them or mind-controlling
them, or even shape shifting to steal a person’s
likeness.
They were taking skin.
These creatures hollowed out Graham, Oh, Annette
and the MTF team, pulling out their innards
and crawling their way inside, filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their internal
organs to rot.
These hollowed out people become vessels for
the entities of SCP-3333 to hide in.
The whole thing had been a trap, intentionally
exploiting human weaknesses, intrigue, unanswered
questions.
You know what they say about curiosity, and
these entities used it to bring more potential
vessels to the top of SCP-3333.
They pretended to be the people who they had
replaced, imitating them so the Foundation
would send more personnel to explore the tower,
increasing their supply of skins.
Graham’s dog tag had revealed the deception,
and Doctor Williams had escaped up SCP-3333.
The members of the research team that had
already been replaced were hot on her tail,
determined to catch and hollow her out too,
and by the end of her video, they had succeeded.
A month later though, a team delivering supplies
realized what had happened and the trapdoor
was sealed.
Suntop Fire Lookout was put under permanent
guard, but at least fifty personnel were killed
or replaced by one of the entities.
A new Mobile Task Force, Lamda-1 “Maxwell’s
Demons” was created to hunt down and neutralize
any of the entities that escaped SCP-3333,
but it’s still unknown how many left the
tower and are still out there somewhere, waiting
to use someone’s curiosity about the strange
and unknown against them.
On a cold October night in 2003, Shirley Yeats
of Seattle, Washington, was just about to
get ready for bed when she heard a knock at
the door.
She approached the door and asked the person
on the other side to identify themselves.
The voice outside responded immediately, it
was a salesman who wanted just a few moments
of Ms. Yeats' time.
This was odd for two reasons - First, it was
almost 10 o'clock at night, much later than
is usual for door to door salesman.
And second, the knock hadn't come from Mrs.
Yeats' front door.
It was coming from the door to her bathroom.
Has your home ever been visited by a door-to-door
salesman?
If you were born in the last forty years,
then your answer to that question is probably
'no'.
In the age of online shopping, the idea of
a salesperson going from house to house hawking
vacuum cleaners or encyclopedia sets feels
like a relic from the past.
It's highly unlikely you'd ever see one walking
the streets nowadays, and equally unlikely
that one would knock on your front door.
However, if you live in Washington State,
you might need to be wary of a certain salesman
who is still doing the rounds.
SCP - 1879, also known as the Indoor Salesman
and the Door Man, is a phenomenon that manifests
randomly in homes throughout Washington.
Subjects will hear persistent knocking from
the interior doors of their homes, and the
affected door becomes classified as SCP - 1879
- 1.
The knocking doesn't stop until the door is
opened, at which point the subject will be
greeted by SCP - 1879 - 2, a Caucasian man
of indeterminate age, standing around 170
cm tall.
The man will claim to be a salesman, and immediately
try to pitch a bizarre product to the subject
whose home he's just invaded.
The SCP Foundation was first alerted to the
existence of the Indoor Salesman when they
intercepted a 911 call coming from the home
of Mrs. Shirley Yeats.
She had opened the door to her bathroom in
an attempt to get the salesman to stop knocking,
and once he was in her home, he refused to
leave.
According to Yeats, he kept disappearing in
and out of random doors in her house.
Foundation Field Agent Rogers was equipped
with a recording device and sent to investigate
the case with several other agents.
When he arrived at the home, he found Mrs.
Yeats inconsolable.
SCP-1879-2 was still rapidly talking at her,
and strangely enough, the product he was holding
and trying to sell to her was a border collie
puppy.
As soon as Agent Rogers entered the room,
the man shifted his attention away from Mrs.
Yeats and towards him.
He then started trying to sell the puppy to
Agent Rogers.
Agent Rogers did not want to purchase this
puppy, but he found that the man spoke so
quickly and urgently, he couldn't get a word
in edgewise.
The man was begging Rogers to take the puppy,
practically shoving it in his face, saying
that he didn’t need any money, and that
the only payment he needed would be 'some
of your time'.
Rogers grew so annoyed at being talked over
and interrupted that he ordered the other
Field Agents to apprehend the Indoor Salesman.
They did so, but as soon as the agents walked
him out the front door of the house, he disappeared
without a trace.
The agents remained in the area to monitor
the situation, and sure enough, SCP-1879-2
manifested again in Mrs. Yeats' home six hours
later, still trying to trade the puppy for
no money, just a little of her time.
12 years to be precise.
After hours and hours of being worn down by
this supernaturally pushy salesman, Yeats
relented and agreed to take the puppy… and
immediately disappeared.
The Indoor Salesman then disappeared himself
through the closest door before he could be
apprehended again.
At a loss for what to do, the agents administered
Class-A amnestics to Mrs. Yeats' family and
left.
The reason for her disappearance wasn't fully
known until 12 years later in 2015, when she
reappeared in the same spot she'd disappeared
from, having no concept of how much time had
passed.
The puppy really had just cost her 12 years
of her life.
Stories like that of Shirley Yeats have popped
up all over the state in the years since,
from Everett to Walla Walla and everywhere
in between.
Due to the random nature of SCP-1879 events
and the way that the Indoor Salesman can disappear
instantly in and out of any door in a building,
the SCP Foundation has been unable to capture
him.
The best they’ve been able to do is monitor
911 calls from across the state, listening
for key words that might indicate another
SCP-1879 infestation.
When such an event is reported, the foundation
deploys Mobile Task Force Rho-4, aka “Shoos
Salesmen.”
This task force's entire purpose is to minimize
the amount of harm the Indoor Salesman is
able to cause by intercepting him before he
can make a sale.
This is a very important task, as evidenced
by the story of Mrs. Yeats, since while the
products this salesman sells might be innocent,
he doesn't accept payment in any normal currency.
The prices he asks for his products are always
bizarre, and often deadly.
If all someone loses is 12 years of their
life, they could be considered to be getting
off easy.
In one instance, the product being sold was
a single red rose, in exchange for the subject's
heart.
Once the deal was sealed, the subject dropped
dead on the spot, with an autopsy revealing
that his heart and circulatory system vanished
from inside his body.
In another, the Indoor Salesman offered 220
bananas, and told the subject to simply 'give
him some sugar'.
The subject agreed, and all candied goods
in the home disappeared.
In a third, the Indoor Salesman was trying
to sell a thermonuclear warhead, the price
of which was the subject's soul.
The subject accepted, and at first, nothing
seemed to have happened.
The Foundation confiscated the warhead and
placed it into non-anomalous containment.
Later that day, the subject went to listen
to some music, only to find that two of her
vinyl records had gone missing - Lady Soul
and Almighty Fire, by world-famous soul singer
Aretha Franklin.
So, even though he's incredibly invasive,
annoying, and his transactions can be deadly,
the Indoor Salesman still maintains a sense
of humor.
The fact that the Foundation can't capture
the Indoor Salesman means that a lot of questions
about him remain unanswered.
The biggest by far is why he does what he
does.
In most SCP-1879 events, the Indoor Salesman
seems frantic and desperate to make a sale.
Often he will refer to having quotas and deadlines
to meet, which implies some other, unseen
entity that he has to answer to.
These questions remain unanswered, because
all attempts to interrogate the Indoor Salesman
have been unsuccessful.
When he manifests in a location, it's impossible
to get him to stray from his sales pitch,
and he disappears as soon as he successfully
sells his wares.
However, there was one instance where, after
an SCP-1879 event took place, Foundation agents
were there to witness a rare interaction between
the Indoor Salesman and his mysterious employers.
Agent Rogers and the rest of the Shoos Salesmen
were called out to a home in Spokane where
rapid knocking had begun to emanate from the
bedroom door.
Equipped with recording devices, Rogers was
able to record the voice of the Indoor Salesman
coming from inside the bedroom.
In the recording, the salesman grumbled to
himself about not being able to meet his quota
by tomorrow, saying that if he didn't, he'd
be stuck in this world for the next century.
He started knocking again, yelling through
the door that he knew that he knew they were
home.
He kept knocking until he was interrupted
by the sound of a phone ringing.
The Indoor Salesman was heard picking it up,
and Rogers managed to record the conversation.
The person calling was, apparently, the Indoor
Salesman’s boss, who was calling to complain
about his performance.
Only one side of the conversation was heard,
but evidently the Indoor Salesman’s boss
wasn't too happy about receiving two Aretha
Franklin albums as payment instead of an actual
human soul.
The Indoor Salesman apologized for the joke,
then told his boss - “It won't happen again.
Please don't hurt it, I'll meet the quota
this time, I swear.”
He hung up, grumbling to himself again, “I
better get to move up to at least Accounting
this time....
I've paid my dues and then some.”
Rogers finally opened the door, to the apparent
disappointment of the Indoor Salesman, who
was hoping to speak with the home’s owner
and was quite annoyed at having another one
of his sales interrupted by MTF Rho-4.
Rogers tried to ask the Indoor Salesman who
he'd just been speaking to on the phone, but
as usual, the Salesman started talking over
him.
“Now, see here, let's think logically,”
he said.
“You know I'm not gonna tell you anything.
I know you're not likely to buy what I'm selling.
So let's just move on to greener pastures.
I'm coming up close to a deadline, and I'm
sure you're swamped with making sure good
people don't do their jobs, so I'll just be
on my way and let you do that.
Ciao.”
The Indoor Salesman tried to close the door,
but Agent Rogers blocked it with his arm.
He was tired of this SCP giving him the runaround,
and he was going to keep the Indoor Salesman
here if it was the last thing he did.
He demanded the entity stay and be interviewed,
and other members of the task force apprehended
the Salesman, making sure he couldn't leave
the room.
The Indoor Salesman, now held in place by
several armed men, seemed to finally relent.
He told Rogers - “I'm busy, so I'll tell
you what.
I'm going to give you something, no money
out of your pocket, and we'll call it even.
Sound good?”
Rogers, just wanting to get this whole thing
over with, agreed to these terms.
Three seconds later, every agent on the scene
was dead, and the Indoor Salesman was able
to straighten his tie, pick up his briefcase
and walk through the door to the bathroom.
When the bodies of Agent Rogers and the rest
of MTF Rho-4 were examined by Foundation scientists,
the cause of death was found to be, in every
case, thousands of coins suddenly appearing
in not only their pockets, but also inside
their stomachs, lungs, and even under their
skin.
Later that day, the Indoor Salesman was reported
at a home in the same neighborhood.
He was seen trying to sell the house's owner
- 80-year-old retiree Alan Johnson - a Glock-18
pistol in exchange for 'his attention.’
As he had done so many times before, the Indoor
Salesman disappeared through another door
before the Foundation were able to reach the
scene, and when the SCP arrived, they found
Mr. Johnson, still alive but now missing his
prefrontal cortex - the part of the brain
that controls attention.
It's likely that, because of the nature of
the entity, SCP-1879 might be entirely impossible
to contain.
The Foundation might never find out anything
more than what they already know about the
Indoor Salesman, the way he's able to manifest
behind closed doors, or the reason he has
to keep filling quotas for an unseen boss
who, apparently, doesn't have a very good
sense of humor.
So, if you're ever in Washington state, be
careful who you open your doors to, especially
if the knocking you hear is coming from inside
your house.
In a remote part of Russia, a mysterious disease
outbreak was tearing through a tiny farming
village with terrifying side effects.
There was no cure, no clue to where it came
from, and worst of all, the disease’s terrifying
impact didn’t end with death.
No, it was after those carrying the disease
died, that the real horror started.
After an agonizing fever that leaves the victims
writhing in pain, they quickly succumb to
the disease, only to rise from their graves
to wreak havoc on the living.
The virus continues to spread, until the corpses
outnumber those trying to hide from them,
as the world spirals into almost certain ruin.
It sounds like the plot of a zombie movie,
but for the SCP Foundation this is anything
but fiction, and the terror that unfolded
in that little Siberian town is the first
recorded encounter with SCP - 610, also known
as, The Flesh That Hates.
First, livestock began to vanish from farms.
Theft or wild animals were suspected, but
no suspects could be found, and no mutilated
remains turned up.
The animals weren’t being stolen, and they
weren’t being eaten, so…what happened
to them?
With no more animals left to lose, the farmers
themselves then began to disappear, but the
authorities refused to take the missing persons
cases seriously.
The missing farmers’ families would contact
the police, make a report, and then the whole
thing was forgotten.
It was written off just as another unsolved
disappearance, which wasn’t uncommon in
the wild and unforgiving region.
Then the police themselves began to disappear.
The families of the missing farmers would
sometimes report strange sounds from the surrounding
woods, describing moans and inhuman screeches
of pain.
One young boy reported seeing a cow with what
he described as “tentacles” lurking around
the edge of the trees.
Regional police were dispatched to the location,
and ordered to investigate and report back
on their findings within 24 hours.
But the units sent to the area didn’t report
back, and were never heard from again.
Upon learning of the reports, the Russian
government grew increasingly concerned, fearing
domestic insurgency or foreign espionage of
some kind could be at play.
They sent a small team of special agents to
the area, and, one by one, those agents disappeared,
just like the others before them.
It seemed no one who went into the village
after the disappearances started ever came
out again.
They had all simply vanished.
Desperate for answers, the Russian government
contacted the only people in the world who
could help - The SCP Foundation.
What the Foundation found over the course
of their investigation would shock and unnerve
them, going beyond anything they had previously
discovered.
Before the investigation officially began,
the affected area was sealed off by the Russian
government.
Not knowing if it would be safe to send researchers
into the containment perimeter, the Foundation
set up a small camera mounted unit, nicknamed
Herbie, to capture footage of whatever remained
of the village.
The images captured by Herbie revealed what
exactly had become of the people in this doomed
village, and the true, nightmarish nature
of SCP-610.
SCP-610 is a Keter-class entity, meaning it’s
an anomaly that’s exceedingly difficult
to contain consistently or reliably, with
containment procedures often being extensive
and complex.
610 is a highly contagious skin disease that
initially manifests like an ordinary allergic
reaction, with symptoms including increased
sensitivity, itching, and a rash.
But within just three hours of those initial
symptoms appearing, the rash starts to turn
into masses of scar tissue on the chest and
arms.
These masses spread over the legs and back
of the victim, and completely consume them
in thick, rubbery flesh within five hours.
Once they’re covered, the victim will cease
all vital functions.
Unfortunately for them, and doubly so for
those around them, they do not stay dead.
About three minutes after expiring, the victim’s
vitals will restart at a heightened rate,
and the masses of flesh encasing their body
will begin to move and multiply, mutating
them into a form beyond anything resembling
the human they once were.
The specific type of mutation varies from
case to case, but has included the head becoming
massive and bulbous, the growth of extra limbs,
and, in especially gruesome cases, the victim’s
body splitting apart to allow extra tendrils
of flesh to sprout from the open wound.
Occasionally, an infected person will stop
moving and become rooted to the ground in
a set location.
Once it is settled, their flesh will spread
itself across the ground, encasing all nearby
objects in flaps of scar tissue.
The infected that maintain their mobility
are highly aggressive, even violent, and will
attempt to infect any living thing that comes
into their line of sight.
The disease does not only infect humans, and
can take over any living organism within a
matter of hours.
Due to the highly contagious and dangerous
nature of the disease, safe observation of
infected specimens and areas is only possible
with drones and mounted cameras.
This brings us back to Herbie, the first such
mounted camera to record footage of the infected
area.
Herbie was deployed into the infection site,
also known as Site A, without any damage.
It remained at the outside perimeter of the
village for two hours, observing several infected
humans, and fire damage to many of the homes,
before following an infected into an intact
house.
Herbie’s camera feed captured the infected
person entering the house and sitting down
at the table inside.
There were several other infected humans in
the house, and one unidentified infected creature
that remained immobile under the table.
After viciously assaulting one of the other
infected humans, the infected returned to
the table and began to lay out plates on top
of it.
Pieces of its flesh began to wriggle and tear
away from its body, before settling onto each
plate.
Once the plates were filled, the infected
sitting at the table began to grab at the
flesh and crush it into their mouths, in a
perverse imitation of a normal mealtime gathering.
After capturing this stomach-churning display,
Herbie left the house and continued to explore
the village.
It recorded footage of a large stack of bodies
that seemed to be made up of both Russian
military and civilians, with an infected sitting
on top.
As Herbie maneuvered toward the remains of
the town hall, an infected grabbed the rover
off of the ground.
Herbie’s camera was able to capture the
face of the infected that grabbed the rover.
The face was that of a young girl around ten
years old, strangely intact atop a large,
distorted body.
The final moments of Herbie’s camera feed
captured the infected girl’s face bursting
open, revealing tendrils of flesh that pulled
Herbie into the gaping maw.
Then, the feed cut to black.
Herbie was regarded as lost, but the video
feed briefly resumed five hours later, showing
the camera covered with an unidentified slime.
After this, the video feed was cut for good,
and Herbie abandoned in Site A.
The Foundation has sent several manned expeditions
into Site A, where many expedition forces
have fallen victim to the infected.
Several operatives were also lost in an earthquake
that revealed a network of underground tunnels.
A manned expedition into these tunnels was
attempted, and the video feed that was captured
by the researchers on the expedition was deeply
disturbing.
There were images of an abandoned church filled
with infected, and a mass of uninfected or
partially infected human captives.
The final moments of the video feed from this
expedition captured several operatives being
murdered by an infected human wielding a farming
scythe, indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple weaponry in addition to brute
force.
The use of this weapon, paired with the presence
of captives in the underground tunnels, paints
a terrifying picture of the kind of organization
the infected are capable of.
No more manned expeditions have been attempted,
or, if they have, they have been highly classified.
Ordinarily, once a new SCP is discovered,
it is placed in containment at the Foundation,
with special procedures in place, so that
it can be studied or even neutralized in the
rare occasions where it’s deemed necessary.
When it comes to SCP-610 though, containment
might just be impossible.
It simply covers too much area, and is too
dangerous to expose to human researchers.
Instead, all infected areas have been isolated
with the permission of the Russian government.
There is an official perimeter established
around these areas, and any civilians that
approach them are told to leave under the
pretense of ongoing military operations.
For once, a top secret military project is
the more innocent answer.
Armed guards are placed at the perimeter of
every infected area, and any living thing
with symptoms of SCP-610 spotted near the
perimeter is to be immobilized, killed, and
burned from as far away as possible.
Any living thing that comes in contact with
SCP-610, whether a soldier, a scientist, or
a civilian, is immediately terminated, and
their remains destroyed.
If someone comes within three meters of an
infected organism, they will be quarantined
and remotely examined to determine if they
have been infected.
While the spread of SCP-610 can be airborne,
it has been determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as opposed
to physical contact.
The infection sites remain active to this
day, like modern day leper colonies.
Though they are isolated from the general
population, and the military is doing everything
in their power to contain the infected, SCP-610
is still very much alive.
It is rare for an entity to exist that the
Foundation cannot truly contain, but can only
try to guard against, and that makes this
infection all the more terrifying.
Who knows how much it has mutated over the
years, growing, spreading, hungry for new
hosts?
There is still so much that the Foundation
does not know about the Flesh That Hates,
such as how it works, what it can do, or even
where it came from, since the origin of the
first infection is still, at this point, entirely
unknown.
It has shown itself to be capable of learning,
planning, and protecting itself, so who is
to say that it couldn’t figure out a way
to escape from its isolated area?
It is so highly contagious, and spreads so
quickly, that just one tiny, infected rabbit,
and one inattentive soldier, could be enough
for SCP-610 to reach the general population.
If it did, its violent, destructive nature
and hatred for all life would mean that everything,
not just the people but animals, plants, and
the world itself, could be at risk.
And no one is ready for this kind of infection.
A disease that turns the human body against
itself, turns our skin into a weapon and a
tomb, stripping away identity, humanity, and
everything that isn’t made of that same
hateful flesh.
So, let’s hope that the perimeter holds,
and, the next time you feel a little itchy,
try not to think about what might happen next.
Addiction.
It takes many forms and wears many faces,
like a demon walking among us.
It takes over your life - crawling in and
changing you from the inside out.
Breaking an addiction is hard, but oftentimes
not giving it up is much harder.
That was a difficult lesson to learn for three
people: Joey Walker, Dolly McGregor, and Paul
Ables.
These three had never met one another, and
now, they never will, but each of them had
two things in common.
First was that they each had an addiction
they felt like they couldn’t shake, and
the second was that they each had a run-in
with SCP-666.
Joey Walker was at the end of his rope when
he encountered it.
Everyone has bad days, but for Joey, every
day for the last fifteen years has been a
bad day.
He was pushing 40 with nothing to show for
it, except credit card debt, a scraggly beard,
and a beat-up old Mustang.
But booze had always been there for him.
No matter how bad things got, he could always
count on a glass full of comfort at the end
of the day.
But to paraphrase a quote by Stephen King,
“Sometimes, when a man takes a drink, the
drink takes the man.”
And Joey Walker had been long since taken.
He was a transient worker, doing jobs wherever
jobs needed doing, but he never expected that
he would end up all the way to Tibet working
construction.
Not that he was complaining - Sure, it was
cold, but there was plenty of Tibetan Chang
to enjoy.
It was a drink so good that legends even say
that Yetis would raid villages in the mountains
to get a little taste.
Joey had taken a liking to the Chang, and
it was what he had been drinking when he crashed
his car up in the mountains, leaving him stranded
in the snow.
Joey had survived the crash itself, but he
knew he wouldn’t last long in the cold.
He needed shelter.
That’s why he felt like he could hardly
believe his luck when he first saw the Yurt
- a kind of traditional, Tibetan tent made
from animal skins.
Joey had never seen anything quite like it,
but any refuge from the storm would do.
He pushed forward through the snow and climbed
inside.
But the inside of the Yurt was nothing like
the outside.
In fact, it seemed like an exact replica of
his favorite sports bar back in Atlantic City.
It was warm, there was all the old memorabilia
on the walls, and every screen was showing
the Saints wiping the floor with the Colts
in the 2010 Superbowl.
Joey didn’t even question it.
He just smiled, and approached the bar.
He even recognized the bartender - Malcolm,
a good old friend of his.
Malcolm smiled back at him, but there was
something oddly menacing in his grin.
“Welcome back,” he said.
“I thought you’d hauled your sorry keister
off to Tibet.
Guess you gave up on that too, just like everything
else.
Well, except…”
Malcolm pushed a glass of beer towards him
across the bar, and glared.
Joey didn’t understand why Malcolm was being
so aggressive, but he didn’t question that,
either.
He grabbed the glass and drank up, guzzling
it down before slamming the empty glass down
on the bar.
Malcolm kept the drinks coming, round after
round after round, and Joey kept knocking
them back.
He didn’t notice when the TV screens turned
to static.
He didn’t notice when the other patrons
at the bar began to jitter and twitch, turning,
little by little, into something less than
human.
He didn’t even notice when Malcolm’s face
started melting off his skull, as long as
he kept pouring.
Before he could even really understand what
was happening to him, Joey Walker was dead.
His liver and kidneys had given out on him.
His corpse would later be found, frozen on
the Tibetan mountainside, just thirty feet
away from his crashed car.
The coroner’s report would list his cause
of death as, “Accidental.”
But this was no accident.
He’d fallen victim to SCP-666, an anomalous
Yurt known to some as the Spirit House.
The being he’d called Malcolm is known to
the Foundation as SCP-666-1, and Malcolm had
failed its challenge.
Sadly for our inebriated friend, the penalty
for failure is death.
Next on our list of human tragedies comes
Dolly McGregor, a 62-year-old woman from Anaheim,
California.
Dolly was never averse to the drink, but she
knew how to enjoy her Mojitos in moderation.
You rarely get to 62 if you don’t, and Dolly
could tell people with pride that she had
two children, and six grandchildren, whom
she didn’t see nearly often enough for her
liking.
She also had over $100,000 in gambling debt
owed to a number of Casinos on the Vegas Strip.
Ever since her husband, Albert, had passed
away several years prior, shooting craps,
playing blackjack, and whiling away the hours
in front of the slot machines had been a welcome
change from loneliness.
But in Vegas, fortunes can change in an instant
- Dolly had gone from being on a hot winning
streak to losing everything.
The casinos extended her lines of credit until
she was gambling with money she’d never
be able to pay back, but that didn’t stop
her.
She’d been selling off everything, even
remortgaging the house that Albert had built
with his own two hands to try and keep up
with her ballooning debts.
Still, it wasn’t enough, but she couldn’t
stop, either.
It wasn’t even that she felt good about
it anymore, it was just that she only ever
felt normal among the flashing lights of slot
machines and the clatter of dice.
She needed to get away; as far away as possible.
She’d heard about people reaching spiritual
enlightenment in Tibet.
They’d discovered God, or Gods, or sometimes
just a sense of inner peace.
Whatever it was, she needed to find it and
to get this demon off her back.
So she took the last of her savings and flew
off to Tibet to clear her head.
She didn’t know if there were any casinos
in Lhasa, but if there were, her money would
surely be no good there.
It was exactly what she needed.
But Tibet wasn’t the promised land she thought
it would be.
Wherever Dolly went, there she was, with the
same vices and demons chasing her.
The first night she spent in Lhasa, she used
the hotel wifi to download an online poker
app on her phone.
This culminated in another couple thousand
dollars lost, and a panic attack that caused
Dolly to throw her phone into her toilet before
wandering off into the wilderness.
She just needed to get away.
But time and space got away from her, and
eventually, she was knee deep in the snow.
Where had she come from?
Where could she go?
It quickly dawned on her that, if she didn’t
find some kind of shelter soon, she’d be
done for.
But all she could do was keep walking…
That’s when she happened upon SCP-666.
The Yurt was like an oasis on the barren mountainside.
She didn’t expect comfort inside, but it
could at least provide her some shelter until
the staff back at the hotel noticed she was
gone.
Then they’d come and save her, right?
Right?
But when she passed through the yak-leather
flap into the Yurt, Dolly wasn’t in an ancient
tent in the Tibetan wilderness, she was on
a casino floor.
There was a big, beautiful roulette table
before her, attended to by a grinning, well-dressed
croupier.
They were flanked by an army of slot machines,
and all the pleasing, familiar sounds of cheerful
gambling rang out through the air.
She approached the table, and the croupier
shook his head in what seemed like disappointment.
“Back again, eh, Dolly?” he said with
a sigh.
“Of course, I should have expected it.
After all, what else do you have in that empty
little life of yours, hmm?
Without all this, you’d be nothing, right?
Nothing at all.
Since Albert died and the kids want nothing
to do with you, we’re all you’ve got.
So, Dolly, what’ll it be - Red or black?
Are you feeling lucky?”
His words wounded Dolly, but that wouldn’t
stop her.
She grabbed her chips, and put them all on
red.
One last spin couldn’t hurt.
What did she have to lose?
She blinked, and she wasn’t sitting at the
table anymore.
She was upright, but she wasn’t standing.
Her wrists and ankles were bound to something
- to a wheel, a giant roulette wheel, like
it was some medieval torture device.
The croupier was standing across from her.
Well, something that used to be a croupier.
His face was flickering in and out; sometimes
it was human, sometimes it was a mess of eyes
and teeth.
More demons were sitting at all the slot machines
behind him, pulling levers made from human
bones.
“Good choice, Dolly,” the croupier said.
“Red suits you.”
He reached out and gave the wheel a spin.
Dolly was lost in an overwhelming, pulsing
cascade of lights, colors, and sounds.
The horrific, tinny noises of slot machines
and the laughter of the demonic croupier.
She was lost in panic and terror as she just
kept spinning, and spinning, and spinning…
When her body was eventually found, her muscles
were in the advanced stages of atrophy, as
though she hadn’t been moving for years.
Her brain was rotted, and the cause of death
was determined as sudden cardiac arrest after
an extended period of sleep-deprivation and
malnutrition.
Dolly’s family would never really know what
happened to her.
The SCP Foundation had learned a lot about
SCP-666 after containing it in Site 73.
Its anomalous effects namely, vivid, complex,
and potentially fatal hallucinatory experiences
only affect those with some kind of addiction
or dependency.
To anyone else entering the Yurt, it’s just
a normal tent.
But any addicts who enter will fall under
its spell, and are generally transported back
to the place they were when their addiction
was at its strongest.
There, they’ll encounter SCP-666-1, an entity
that takes the form of a figure from the subject’s
life - normally one heavily involved in facilitating
their addiction.
Any kind of addiction seems to trigger it
- alcohol, drugs, gambling, pornography, food,
self-destructive behavior, even video games.
SCP-666 kills its victims with a twisted mockery
of the very thing they were dependent on in
life.
It was only with Paul Ables that the Foundation
started discovering the other side of the
coin.
By almost all accounts, Paul is a worse person
than anyone on this list.
He got addicted to hard drugs early on in
life, and took up a life of violent crime
to support his habit.
He murdered two people during a liquor store
robbery, before being convicted and sentenced
to death.
He’d then been picked up as a D-Class by
the SCP Foundation, and selected as a test
subject for SCP-666 due to his history of
drug abuse.
The Foundation expected to be adding his body
to the incineration pile sometime soon.
None of the researchers working on the case
predicted what actually ended up happening.
Paul was forced to enter the Yurt.
Not long after, he found himself standing
in a place he’d done everything to try to
forget: The dark, graffiti-stained alley where
he’d been sold his first hit.
This was the place.
The place that destroyed his life.
Every bad decision he’d ever made could
be traced back to here.
And specifically to one man…
Frank.
Frank was his first dealer, and how here he
was, standing right across from him once more.
Frank was grinning like a demon.
“C’mon, Paulie,” he said.
“You’re gutter trash.
We both know what you’re going to do.
Don’t you feel it?
The itch?
One more hit, Paulie, that’s all you need
to feel better.
It’s time to take your medicine…”
Frank - or this thing, pretending to be Frank
- was right.
He did feel the itch.
He did want it.
Maybe he was no better than this.
He began to reach out towards Frank, but then
he abruptly pulled his hand back.
Frank’s eyes widened in genuine surprise,
as Paul replied, “I’m sorry.
That’s not me anymore.”
SCP-666-1 gave a smile, and said, “Maybe
it isn’t, Paulie, maybe it isn’t…”
When Paul Ables was removed from the SCP-666
Yurt by one of the attending guards, the Foundation
researchers discovered something amazing.
Paul was very much alive, and more incredibly,
he didn’t feel the cravings anymore.
His addiction was gone.
And further tests showed that Paul wasn’t
a one-off event.In fact, anyone who denies
the temptation of SCP-666 will see their addictions
miraculously disappear when they finally leave.
After this it became clear to the Foundation
that SCP-666 isn’t just a way to punish
addicts, it’s a kind of test.
Those who want to change, who are willing
to truly confront their demons and resist
the pull of temptation are rewarded with the
one thing they want most in life, freedom
from their addiction.
SCP-666 can be your doom or your salvation.
And like most things in life, you get what
you give.
In almost all respects, Kevin O’Reilly is
your average 50-something Irish Man.
He lives in County Cork with his wife, Martha
where he spends his days working at a local
accountancy firm, and during his free evenings,
he likes to take quiet walks through the nearby
woods.
There’s only one remarkable thing that can
be said about Kevin: He was the second human
ever to encounter an example of SCP-3199,
a dangerous Keter-Class anomaly that has the
power to knock humanity off the top of the
food chain if left unchecked.
We know what you’re thinking: What about
the first human?
Don’t worry, we’ll get to him, but we
can assure you: He’s anything but unremarkable.
Back to Kevin.
He was enjoying one of his nightly walks when
he heard a horrible shrieking sound in the
distance.
It sounded like a woman was being murdered
and just hearing it chilled poor Kevin to
his core.
His first instinct was to run to the woman’s
aid and do whatever he could, but there was
a lurking anxiety under the surface.
The echoing memory of an old childhood legend:
The Banshee.
A monstrous, ghostly woman of Irish folklore,
whose blood-curdling screams always foretell
death.
But those were all just stories, surely?
Grim omens to stop children from straying
too far from the path.
Kevin took his first brave step in the direction
of that awful screaming, repeating the quiet
mantra of “There’s no such thing as monsters”
to himself again and again.
If only he knew just how wrong he was.
He ran deeper into the forest, following the
awful sounds.
Whoever this woman was, she certainly had
some pipes on her - the screaming had been
going on for minutes on end now, and it didn’t
seem to show any signs of subsiding.
The sky above had darkened from evening to
full on night by the time Kevin reached the
source of the screaming.
Kevin found himself in a clearing in the forest,
but in all his years of walking down here,
he’d never seen it before.
There was a ramshackle old cottage, rotten
with age and damp, and next to it, a rusty
old hut made from corrugated iron.
Like a kind of oversized chicken coop.
From the tinny, echoing quality of the screams,
he knew that they were coming from inside
the hut.
Was a woman being held captive here?
Kevin was a smart man.
He approached the tin hut quietly, not saying
a word.
If this woman had indeed been captured and
was now being held against her will, it wouldn’t
help the situation to potentially alert her
captor to his presence.
This quick thinking is the reason that Kevin
O’Reilly is still alive today.
Because, when he arrived outside the tin hut
and peered in through the window, what he
saw inside was not a woman.
In fact, it wasn’t even human.
The beast that Kevin saw inside the hut was
nothing short of a crime against nature.
A twisted abomination that was only vaguely
humanoid.
Its bloated, fleshy body, dripped with some
kind of viscous fluid, and it looked more
like a plucked, rotten chicken than a person.
The creature was shrieking and wailing, its
huge body convulsing in the coop.
It was making a gurgling, gagging noise, like
something was strangling it.
Kevin felt like he was going to be sick.
But the monster beat him to it.
It doubled over, its wretched, lipless mouth
stretching open to freakish proportions, and
started to vomit something out.
It was a gray, leathery mass, covered in dark
red blood, that soon flopped out onto the
ground, among a number of other masses that
looked just like it.
The creature then gave one final wail, and
spewed out a red stream of blood and bile
onto the masses.
That’s when Kevin realized what he was looking
at: Eggs.
A pile of big, unnatural eggs.
The foul-smelling bile that the creature had
just vomited up had no effect on the eggs,
but it seemed to burn and corrode the surrounding
environment.
It hissed against the metal as thin wisps
of steam rose from the scorch marks.
Kevin was horrified but also entranced by
the bizarre sight - until the creature stood
back up, and began to turn towards him.
Kevin didn’t let his morbid curiosity get
the better of him.
He turned and sprinted out of the forest,
knowing that if he lingered for even a second
longer, he wouldn’t return home alive.
He ran and ran, and finally heard the wailing
fade into the distance behind him.
This was the first ever outside brush with
a specimen of SCP-3199, also known as “Humans,
Refuted.”
Sadly, it would be far from the last, and
would remain one of the rare few that wasn’t
deadly.
When Kevin got back to town he immediately
told everyone what he saw.
There’s a monster in the woods, and it’s
breeding!
He even told the local newspaper, which printed
the headline, “BEAST SIGHTED IN LOCAL FOREST.”
It was enough to get the SCP Foundation’s
attention.
Field Agents were sent to the town proper
to suppress the information leaking about
the creature and gather any additional information
they needed to assess whether they were dealing
with a real anomaly here, or just another
crank.
Straight away though, the agents could tell
from Kevin’s demeanor that he’d seen something
truly awful.
He was given amnestics, and Mobile Task Force
Omega-19 were dispatched to secure and contain
the creatures that Kevin had seen.
They had twelve well-armed personnel, trained
and prepared to deal with anything.
Or so they thought.
They were led by Corporal Duncan, a seasoned
MTF operative, and they used state of the
art night vision technology to gain a tactical
advantage in the dead of night.
All they had to work on though was the visual
description provided by Mr. O’Reilly.
It didn’t take long for them to find the
same clearing out in the woods.
There was the rotten old cottage and the metal
“coop”, just like Kevin had described.
Two younger MTF members, Private MacLeod and
Private Langley, were eager to take the lead
and prove themselves as they explored the
dilapidated nightmare of a house.
Once inside, they heard strange noises, what
they assumed must have been footsteps coming
from deeper in the home.
They crept further in, and that’s when Private
Macleod first noticed it: The shape of a large,
pale, bulbous figure at the end of a long
hallway, shivering slightly in the cold.
Compared to some of the hardened killers he’d
heard about in combat training, this creature
looked like a piece of cake.
This half-man, half-chicken - it was almost
a walking joke.
He leveled his weapon and grinned as he approached
the creature.
But Private Macleod had made a fatal mistake:
He underestimated his enemy.
In a later Foundation debriefing interview,
Corporal Duncan would report with a dull horror
what he saw happen to Private Macleod that
terrible day.
He’d never seen a smile fade from someone’s
face so fast, as the creature turned, shrieked,
and sprinted down the hallway towards Private
Macleod.
The poor Private barely even had time to raise
his gun, his hands quivering with panic.
Though even if Macleod had been quicker on
the draw, it probably wouldn’t have saved
him.
As the beast approached, it spewed its foul,
stinking red bile out onto Macleod’s face.
It was a sudden burning sensation so powerful
that he passed out in an instant, his lower
face dripping off of his own skull.
He was dead in mere moments.
Then, the beast leapt forwards and began attacking
Private Langley, biting and striking and spewing
more of its deadly acidic liquid.
By the time it was done, there was barely
any of Langley left to retrieve from the house.
The ten surviving task force members opened
fire on the creature, but along with being
surprisingly fast it could also apparently
take quite a licking.
Even when Corporal Duncan managed a direct
hit on the creature’s chest, blowing a portion
of it away, the monster just let out the most
awful scream and continued fighting.
Corporal Duncan admits that, to this day,
that scream, and the moonlight shining through
the hole in the creature’s chest continue
to haunt him.
When the monster was finally subdued, they
were able to take it back to the nearby evac
chopper and begin the journey to the nearest
containment facility.
But things took another terrible turn during
that fateful flight.
The creature’s body began to convulse, before
vomiting out a pair of large, leathery eggs.
Without a moment’s hesitation, the eggs
began to bulge and tear open, and a pair of
rapidly-growing SCP-3199 instances crawled
out, attacking the mobile task force members
huddled together in the cramped confines of
the helicopter.
Once the second onslaught was over, only four
of the remaining ten members of personnel
were left alive.
The Foundation had discovered a formidable
new foe.
The specimens were brought back to Site-114,
and placed in a modified version of the standard
Keter-Class containment chamber.
It was fitted with acid-resistant steel walls,
and a series of transparent resin blocks to
store the specimens inside for constant observation.
But the creatures weren’t given Keter Class
for nothing: Escape attempts are frequent,
and whenever they happen, the numbers of creatures
in containment increases.
The most frightening detail of SCP-3199 is
the fact that it’s impossible to reduce
the number of them in existence.
Each creature has a unique, stomach-like organ
inside its body which holds an egg in reserve.
While it’s possible to destroy one of the
creatures, the eggs have proven to be almost
indestructible.
As a result, when one of them dies, the egg
within it hatches and immediately grows into
a replacement.
And if the creatures are ever allowed to roam
free, they begin laying eggs in any unoccupied
space they can find, causing their numbers
to grow.
In theory, if left unchecked, they could supplant
the human race with their own species in hardly
any time at all.
The only solution that the Foundation has
found is submerging the creatures in sedative-laced
water, as the beasts seem to inherently register
water-filled areas as “occupied space”,
and therefore do not begin laying eggs while
submerged.
But even the Foundation’s most optimistic
minds still admit this is only a temporary
solution.
But where did these awful creatures come from?
After the chaos of the first mission, the
Foundation had dispatched an additional Mobile
Task Force, Surface Team Delta-029-E, to perform
a second sweep of the house and figure out
what had been going on during the two decades
of proceeding silence.
Inside, the team managed to collect a number
of strange objects to bring back as evidence
of the peculiar activities that had taken
place there
Among these were a number of chicken carcasses
that bore evidence of surgical dissection,
a pair of chicken feather quills, and an A5
hard-cover notebook labeled “NEW BREED MANIFESTO.”
Its writer is believed to be deceased, most
likely as a result of SCP-3199, but the final
note scrawled inside the book and dated 1973
provides some insight into what had occurred
inside that dilapidated shack in Ireland.
It reads:
“If you're reading this, then lucky, lucky
you!
400,000 hour from now and it'll be warm
and wet and warm, and the wonderful vursatilli
vessa versatility of (INFERIOR) human DNA
will birth a better era.
A stronger era.
One where [ILLEGIBLE] and food and water will
be nothing but things of the passed as we
make and make and make more until until
I REALLY HAVEN'T MUCH TIME
TIME
THATS why i ENVY you so so so much.
you'll have all the time you need.
time will be a thing of the time will be on
and on and death will be life.
life new life needs things to live.
new life will be a part of life from now on.”
These are the last words of the deranged mad
scientist who created SCP-3199, perhaps under
the demented belief that somehow, they’d
make the world a better place.
Personally, we don’t think SCP-3199 have
any interest in improving the world, but whether
we like it or not, their insane creator is
right about one thing: They’re our problem
now.
Agent Carla Mendoza was one of the best field
agents that Site 41 had ever seen.
She was professional, cool under pressure,
and when the situation demanded it, she could
be a straight-up badass.
During a Chaos Insurgency raid on the Site,
she’d single handedly killed four different
insurgents - the last one with her bare hands.
During containment breaches, she’d always
be the first one charging into the fray, her
Foundation standard-issue Beretta drawn and
ready to fire.
Agent Mendoza was so devoted to the job that
she took up the Site Director’s offer to
start living onsite, so she could always be
there to help if an emergency situation unfolded.
After all, when it all hits the fan, you want
someone as utterly unshakeable as Agent Mendoza
on your side.
The job had thrown the worst of the worst
at her, and she’d never even flinched.
So surely, nothing could scare Agent Mendoza,
right?
Right?
After a long day of kicking ass, taking names,
and filling in the properly mandated amount
of SCP Foundation debriefing paperwork, Agent
Mendoza retired to her Site 41 quarters.
She felt exhausted and sweaty, so before heading
to bed to watch some wonderful SCP Explained
videos on her phone, she decided to take a
quick shower.
The last thing she expected was for this particular
shower to become...well, let’s say “Hitchcockian.”
The water was running, hot and clean, filling
the air with steam.
Agent Mendoza was lathering up her hair when
she first heard the noise: Heavy, wheezing
breaths coming from just behind the shower
curtain.
The second she heard it, Agent Mendoza felt
a kind of brutal, crushing anxiety that she’d
never experienced before.
Like a hand was reaching into her chest, and
squeezing her heart.
The self-defense training that’d been encoded
into her muscle memory over years of working
at the Foundation kicked into effect.
In a blind panic, she struck out at the shower
curtain, causing it to sway outwards - and
land directly on the face of Mendoza’s wheezing
voyeur.
Who or whatever it was, it was standing right
there, less than a meter away from the shower.
That wheezing carved into Mendoza’s ears
like a butcher’s knife.
What an awful, monstrous sound.
And despite the fact that the shower curtain
obscured its face, she could still somehow
see it, the way a defenseless animal can sense
an approaching predator without ever locking
eyes on it - and just somehow know that it’s
too late for them to escape now.
Every training session, every achievement,
every piece of battle-hardening experience
- it all evaporated in the presence of that
thing.
Mendoza was so terrified, she might as well
have been a child.
The monster just stood there beyond the curtain,
its raw, fleshy face parted into a freakishly
wide, yellow-toothed grin.
She didn’t know how, but on some deep, primal
level, she was aware that if this thing got
its hands on her, something horrific beyond
description would happen to her.
She was too terrified to even move a muscle
in its presence.
She remained like that, standing in the shower
and sobbing quietly, for the next three solid
hours until the creature finally disappeared.
When her colleagues found her, she’d experienced
moderate scalding wounds from the hot water
of the shower.
It took another several hours for Agent Mendoza
to compose herself enough to share her story.
A couple of days later, Tim Ellis, a junior-level
filing clerk, was found trapped in a Site
41 supply closet.
He’d urinated in his Foundation-issue slacks,
and was in a state of borderline catatonia.
When his superiors asked him why he’d been
spending two hours in a supply closet on company
time, he reported that it was because a monster
had appeared outside the door when he was
searching for a replacement stapler.
Despite never actually opening the door to
see what was outside or call for help - Mr.
Ellis said that he felt as though he would
have had a heart attack if he actually opened
that accursed door - he was able to provide
a clear description of the monster.
He said it was tall and emaciated, with reddish-brown
skin that made it seem almost burnt or rotten.
While it stood there and waited beyond the
supply closet door, it let out the most awful
wheezing noise, like an old, rusty Iron Lung.
But the image that Ellis seemed most fixated
on was the monster’s face, or lack thereof:
Just a huge, grinning mouth that covered up
its entire head, stocked with an arsenal of
massive, yellow teeth.
Ellis was visibly shivering as he talked about
it.
Two incidents are an unpleasant coincidence,
but three are a bonafide pattern, and it didn’t
take long for more sightings of this strange
new anomaly - dubbed SCP-303, or The Doorman
- to pop up across the site.
It earned that name by always appearing behind
some kind of doorway, or at least a movable
divider, in the case of Agent Mendoza’s
shower curtain.
Whenever it appeared outside a doorway, nearby
Foundation personnel would report being struck
with a sudden paralyzing terror that made
engaging with the creature impossible.
Attempts to call for help were also often
stifled, as the very presence of the Doorman
causes disruptions to electrical equipment.
Whenever The Doorman manifests in your proximity,
it’s safe to say that it’ll be commanding
your absolute, undivided attention.
This was a particularly frightening case for
the SCP Foundation because it was one of the
few anomalies bringing the fight directly
to them.
Most sentient anomalous beings would do anything
to avoid getting captured by the SCP Foundation
and contained in one of their high-security
sites, full of experienced researchers and
state-of-the-art equipment designed specifically
to neutralize their effects.
The Doorman, however, just seemed to take
this as a challenge, turning even the most
hardcore personnel on the site into gibbering
wrecks with its mere presence.
But The Doorman was just getting started.
Agent Henderson had a frightening encounter
in the break room.
He was pulling a long shift, and just wanted
to grab some coffee creamer from the cabinet.
However, as he approached the cabinet, he
heard the telltale wheezing, and that terrible,
overwhelming terror set in once more.
The Doorman was sitting inside the cabinet
in the fetal position, he just knew it.
Could this thing really just appear anywhere
it pleased, and keep people in or out until
it decided to dematerialize and torment somebody
else?
When the creature finally dematerialized and
the cabinet was examined, the coffee creamer
was found to be missing, leaving Agent Henderson
distraught.
This was the first recorded instance of The
Doorman stealing a physical item, but it would
be far from the last.
Henderson wondered whether the creature that’d
just humiliated him was sitting somewhere
else now, sipping from a warm cup of joe with
its big, freakish mouth and laughing at him.
But a few incidents after this, things would
become considerably more serious: The Doorman
was about to take its first life.
Well, it isn’t really that simple, if you
want to get into the semantics of the thing.
When the body of Dr. Barker was found inside
the 2nd-floor storage room after a spree of
SCP-303 incidents, the question was naturally
posed as to whether The Doorman had gotten
more dangerous and finally directly attacked
one of its victims.
Not quite.
There had only been one way in and out of
the storage room: A secured decompression
chamber, and the Doorman had appeared inside
this chamber while Dr. Barker was in the storage
room, effectively trapping him inside with
the sheer terror it causes in its victims.
He was trapped in the room for a grand total
of five days, at which point he finally died
of dehydration, and the Doorman demanifested
shortly afterward.
The staff of Site 41 scaled up their countermeasure
efforts, hoping to discover more about and
perhaps even trap and contain the infamous
Doorman.
Dr. Burroughs, Researcher Matthews, four members
of security personnel, and four D-Class operatives
formed a kind of strike team, ready for quick
dispatches whenever The Doorman happened to
manifest.
It wasn’t long before the creature appeared
in a room on the first floor, but the team
quickly intercepted its location, ready and
eager to gather more data on the mysterious
being that’d been terrorizing all of them
for weeks.
Dr. Burroughs ordered one of the D-Classes
to open the door and look inside, but the
D-Class refused out of fear.
The doctor told him that if he didn’t open
the door, he’d be transferred to SCP-682
duty.
The D-Class frantically shook his head and
said, “I’d rather take my chances with
the reptile than go in there.”
The doctor was getting frustrated.
He told the D-Class that if he didn’t open
the door immediately, he’d be terminated
right there on the spot.
The D-Class still refused, saying that he’d
take death over what the Doorman would do
to him if he stepped inside.
Without hesitation, Dr. Burroughs ordered
one of the security officers to shoot the
D-Class then and there.
The shot was fired.
The D-Class was terminated.
Dr. Burroughs then ordered a female D-Class
who’d just witnessed this callous execution
to open the door, or the same abrupt death
would befall her.
She still refused, then began to describe
the awful things she believed The Doorman
would do to her if she went inside.
Researcher Matthews was visibly shaken by
the descriptions.
Dr. Burroughs decided not to terminate this
D-Class immediately.
He instead wanted to see just how much pressure
the Doorman’s anomalous fear-based resistance
mechanisms could take.
Another D-Class was given a combat knife and
also given the order to cut the female D-Class
with it every time she refused an order to
go inside.
After two hours of repeated asking from Dr.
Burroughs, the female D-Class dropped dead
from blood loss.
At no point did she ever attempt to open the
door.
It seemed that, in all cases for those in
the thrall of the Doorman’s anomalous effects,
death is a truly preferable alternative to
ever facing it head-on.
It’s worth mentioning that these tests were
conducted back in the 1970s, before the formation
of the Foundation’s Ethics Committee, which
explains why their methods feel a little needlessly
cruel.
Since then, The Doorman has fully commandeered
the second-floor storage room, the same one
where it caused Dr. Barker’s death.
It only ever leaves the room to steal more
items from around the site.
These items have included a cryotube, three
sets of standard Foundation surgical equipment,
two D-Class research cadavers, one gasoline-powered
generator, a variety of chemicals from the
chemical storage areas, and of course, poor
Agent Henderson’s can of powdered coffee
creamer.
The reason for the Doorman taking an interest
in these particular items remains unknown,
but we can only assume that nothing good can
come of it.
And there you have it, folks, the strange,
frightening, and eerily inconclusive tale
of The Doorman.
All we can really say is that we’re awfully
glad he’s fixated on bothering Site 41,
because who knows what would happen if he
widened his net to the rest of us?
Thankfully, we won’t need to think about
that.
Oh, that’s odd.
Can you hear that?
I thought I was imagining it.
Though come to think of it, I can’t help
but feel a little uneasy right now.
Do you ever get that feeling you’re being
watched?
Wait...The door, there’s something behind
the door.
Can you feel it?
Can you feel its red flesh and rotten teeth
pressing up against it, breathing, waiting?
Can you feel it staring at you without eyes?
Looking deep into your very soul?
No?
Well, that’s good.
But just stay cautious, okay?
After all, life has many doors, and you never
know who or what will be waiting for you behind
the next one...
It was an old factory in the middle of nowhere,
long-abandoned but still standing.
In the past, it had been filled with workers,
but now nothing ran through it besides the
occasional wildlife.
One July night in 1949 though, four teenagers
decided it would be a good place to explore.
The entrance to the factory was a large, old-fashioned
looking wooden door that was locked tightly
shut.
The teens looked around for another way in,
but couldn’t find one.
What they did find though, was an old iron
lockbox.
After some effort, they managed to get the
box open and found a ring of twelve old, rusted
steel keys sitting inside.
Would these old keys open the wooden door?
Would they find something inside that would
make their night of breaking and entering
worth it?
If only they knew that by unlocking the door
all they would find was true horror… because
they had just found SCP-004, better known
as The 12 Keys and the Door
Not long after the local Sheriff received
a call from three of the panicked teens.
They explained that while trying to get into
the factory, one of their friends had gone
missing.
The local authorities were quickly deployed,
taking the three teens into custody and beginning
a full search of the factory grounds.
The searching sheriff’s department officers
did eventually manage to find a clue as to
what happened to the missing teen, but it
wasn’t a good sign.
It was their severed hand, and even more disturbing
is that it wasn’t discovered outside the
factory, no, it was found over eight kilometers
away.
Soon other body parts were also found, some
as far as thirty-two kilometers away, but
how could the parts of the dead teenager’s
body have been scattered so quickly and so
far from each other?
When the surviving teens were interrogated,
they all repeated the same wild story.
The now dead teen had taken one of the keys
out of the old box they had found and used
it to unlock the strange, old-fashioned wooden
door that led into the factory.
They opened the door and stepped inside, and
the moment they did, they were immediately
torn into pieces that suddenly vanished.
These were no ordinary keys, and this was
no ordinary door.
It was clear this was a job for the SCP Foundation.
An SCP agent was deployed to the site to begin
investigating this anomaly.
After getting the keys from local authorities,
the agent brought in a group of twelve D-class
personnel to test them - one for each key.
And it soon became clear that there was one
effect that was common - ten of the keys seemed
to cause an effect that was completely unsurvivable.
Upon trying the key in the door, the test
subject was immediately torn apart just like
the unfortunate teenager.
While one key caused the body parts to be
scattered in the immediate vicinity, all the
others seemed to vanish into thin air.
But it was the other two keys that proved
to be of even greater interest to the Foundation.
Unlike with all the other tests, the D-class
using the key designated SCP-004-7 was able
to enter the door and return completely unharmed.
But the D-class using SCP-004-12 was a different
story.
Physically, he returned unharmed - but he
seemed barely able to stagger out of the room.
He collapsed, and then began trying to claw
his eyes out in panic and terror.
He was quickly restrained and interrogated,
but he wasn’t coherent enough to give the
Foundation any idea of what lurked behind
the door.
The first D-class to enter using SCP-004-7,
the one who returned intact and sane, only
said that it was a massive room inside - far
bigger than the building appeared from the
outside.
It was determined that the use of this key
was safe enough for further testing.
The door was opened again using the same key
and the Foundation researchers propped it
open so that an armed team could go in and
hopefully come out.
A brief exploration of the massive room showed
some clear anomalous properties - not only
was the room impossible to measure and possibly
limitless in size, it also seemed impossible
to shine any light in the room beyond the
entry and the people inside were the only
objects that could be felt or illuminated.
Whatever this room was, it was keeping its
secrets.
It was clear the site needed to be locked
down.
All the initial witnesses who knew too much
were terminated…
the Foundation was a little
more trigger happy with terminations in the
40s, and the site was quickly locked down
under the auspices of it being dangerous due
to unexploded ordinances.
Fences were placed around the site so that
there would be no more teenage explorations.
The records are spotty and incomplete, but
whatever happened behind those doors during
the initial testing between 1949 and 1950,
the Foundation decided it had learned enough.
The space-time anomalies at play inside of
SCP-004 were deemed too dangerous to explore
further, and the site was sealed off with
all testing suspended.
Whatever was lurking behind those doors, it
would keep its secrets - and the site seemed
easy to secure and contain.
But this was far from the end of SCP-004,
and fifty years later, it made its presence
known again.
It was another July night, many decades after
the unfortunate teenager first opened the
doors to SCP-004.
Only a few pieces of their body had been found,
but suddenly, the rest of the corpse appeared
exactly where they had last been seen - outside
the old wooden door.
Even odder was the fact that even though the
subject had died many years ago their body
was still fresh, as if they had been killed
that same day.
And this wouldn’t be the only sudden reappearance.
Two days later, a second body missing parts
appeared in front of the door.
This was quickly identified as one of the
original twelve test subjects who opened the
door.
Foundation scientists were once again sent
to the site to explore the space-time anomalies,
and it was becoming clear that what went inside
the door didn’t stay there.
It seemed like it went somewhere that didn’t
exist on the same plane as our reality.
And if it could be understood, it could be
used.
On March 21st, 1999 the Foundation began establishing
a site inside of SCP-004, but not for testing
or research purposes.
Nuclear weapons around the world were proliferating
fast, and evidence was mounting that World
War 3 could happen soon.
The Foundation needed a site that could survive
anything - and the mysterious room opened
by the rusted keys seemed like it could be
their salvation.
Supplies would go in the room and would be
preserved there indefinitely, safe from even
nuclear annihilation.
But getting the site set up would pose its
own challenges.
Now dubbed Site 62, the facility was soon
expanded to house certain SCPs as well, in
addition to a super-computer to house all
Foundation data.
This would make it another invaluable backup
in the event of an end-of-the-world event
that necessitated a reboot.
The site was completed over the next year,
during which time they added high-tech containment
units that could hold even the most dangerous
SCP specimens.
Entering and exiting the facility seemed to
pose a risk to those working on it though.
Time no longer behaved like it should, even
when using the one safe key.
People would spend weeks in the site, then
exit claiming they had only been there a few
days.
It was highly unpredictable, and the Foundation
determined that it would be better to eliminate
this X-factor.
All personnel working at Site 62 would now
live on-site permanently, with their families
being told they had died in an accident.
It was August 18th, 2003 when the United States
and Canada were hit with a massive power outage,
knocking out power to many of the Northeast’s
biggest population centers.
While the SCP Foundation has backups on every
site, multiple generators failed, and it was
53 minutes before power could be restored.
During that time, those inside the mysterious
room were plunged into total darkness.
And it soon became clear they weren’t alone.
In the darkened room, the personnel reported
feeling like they were surrounded by people
that shouldn’t be there - and creatures
that shouldn’t exist.
While they couldn’t see anything and nothing
touched them, they were adamant that something
was lurking in that room, and likely had been
for a very long time.
It seemed the limited sources of light may
be the only thing keeping these entities - whatever
they are - at bay.
When testing had resumed on SCP-004 after
the bodies had reappeared outside the door,
the Foundation decided to start exploring
the effects of SCP-004-12 as well.
What about this key caused such psychological
horror that subjects would try to tear out
their own eyes?
This key seemed to drive them insane, and
of the sixteen subjects, only four were still
alive for any length of time after their return.
Most remained in a catatonic state, but one
was given extensive therapy and regained the
ability to communicate, which allowed him
to give the Foundation their best picture
yet of what lurked inside the room.
While the D-Class personnel was still severely
affected by his time in the room and suffered
near-total amnesia, he did remember a few
things.
He remembered deep terror, and memories being
forced into his mind that made no sense as
if they were artificially implanted.
And he remembered not being alone.
He described a massive green being, large
enough that he couldn’t see where it began
and where it ended.
The Foundation didn’t know what it was either.
But what they do know for certain is that
when ten of the keys are used, the door is
opened to a dimension where the laws of physics
are so different that it is completely unsurvivable.
Studies are ongoing as to what makes this
effect so fatal and if there is a way to survive
it, but no answers have been found - and with
only three bodies of victims recovered so
far, there is little evidence
But one object found on-site is of additional
interest.
Discovered roughly a year after the initial
anomaly, in a manager’s office on the factory
grounds, SCP-004-14 seems to be a miniature
version of the anomaly.
It’s a large box made out of wood, and it
is the only other object opened by the one
safe key - as well as five of the other keys
that lead to death when used on the main door.
And this box has unusual properties as well.
It opens automatically, and much like SCP-004’s
room, it seems to be much larger on the inside
than the outside.
It is possible to come in and out safely.
But when the box is locked again, it’s a
different story.
Objects placed in the box don’t seem to
affect its weight, and when the box is closed
and locked, they vanish completely.
Unlike the main room, nothing that’s gone
inside and locked in has ever been recovered.
This includes living beings.
Few answers have been found about where they
go, and it’s possible the box could be used
to dispose of specimens deemed to be too dangerous
- but with no answers about where they go
and when they might come back, this may be
too risky.
Because SCP-004 is fixed in place, special
containment procedures focus on making sure
it stays that way.
It is strictly forbidden to take any of the
other keys through the door, for fear of losing
them or causing it to react in an unpredictable
way.
If the site should be breached, or anything
contained in Site 62 manages escape containment,
the Foundation is ready to activate the on-site
warhead.
Only employees with level 1 clearance can
access the site, and only Level 4s and above
can use the keys - with all knowing that any
attempt to remove the keys from the site will
result in immediate termination.
For now, SCP-004 remains fenced off, with
only select experiments continuing, as the
Foundation tries to unravel its mysteries.
But whatever lurks behind that old wooden
door, it keeps its secrets well.
The SCP Foundation contains a lot of monsters.
From SCP-682, the lizard that refuses to die,
to SCP-939, a species of pack hunters that
steal the voices of their victims – the
dangerous predators that occupy the hundreds
of containment cells of the Foundation make
it their job to hunt and kill innocent people
– or worse.
But have you ever wondered where some of those
monsters come from?
The first encounter that the SCP Foundation
had with SCP-4049 was on July 14th of 2010.
The Foundation operates a massive surveillance
network around the entire world – through
the use of AI, delegated duties, and compartmentalized
information, they’re able to have 911 operators
report any calls that seem anomalous in nature
while knowing nothing about the Foundation
itself.
This way, they’re able to constantly be
aware of anything anomalous going on in the
country that gets reported to 911.
On July 14th, the Foundation was alerted of
a call that likely had an anomalous component.
At first, it didn’t seem like much.
It was to a remote address in Wyoming, outside
of a small town called Gardnerville.
The vacation home of one Richard Samson, a
wealthy businessman in the area, placed right
on the slopes.
The call was made late in the afternoon, by
someone purporting to be the groundskeeper
of the home while Mr. Samson was away.
He was screaming into the phone, terrified
and largely incoherent, but the operator made
out something about a monster attacking the
house.
There was a lot of noise in the background,
sounds of shouting, destruction, and what
sounded like animalistic roars and grunts.
The 911 operator moved the call up, and it
didn’t take long for the Foundation to determine
that something strange was going on here.
They dispatched a handful of agents, deep
undercover as officers with the Wyoming Highway
Patrol, to the address of the home where the
call had come from.
After about half an hour, the agents called
back in to HQ - the scene they had found was
nothing short of gruesome.
Upon arrival, they were greeted with what
appeared to be the aftermath of a particularly
violent and brief tornado.
The entire front section of the ground floor
had been shredded, the gardens trampled, and
the interior utterly destroyed.
The agents picked their way between the wreckage
of the home – it functionally didn’t exist
anymore.
The walls were collapsed from being rammed
and torn through, and the roof had collapsed
in on itself.
The broken shards and pieces of furniture
and wreckage were everywhere.
Despite appearances, this wasn’t a tornado
– a tornado would have thrown the entire
house around.
No, this was as the groundskeeper had said
– something alive, monstrous, and very angry.
Speaking of the groundskeeper, the Foundation
agents began to look for him once they took
stock of the damage to the home.
At first, they couldn’t find him among the
massive pieces of debris and assumed the worst.
Even if whatever had destroyed the house decided
to not kill him, he could easily have been
killed by the collapsing house, buried under
rubble, or a dozen other things.
They picked through the ruins, calling out
that they were from the police and were here
to help.
Eventually, after another half hour of searching,
they heard something.
What sounded like crying and whispering became
audible as the wind died down.
The agents honed in on the noise and found
it was coming from one of the larger piles
of rubble.
After getting some equipment, they were able
to heft up the piece of the collapsed roof,
and found the groundskeeper underneath, curled
into a ball and talking to himself.
He seemed to be in some kind of a panicked
fugue state, not responding to the agents
trying to get through to him.
They wrapped him in a shock blanket and put
him in the back of one of their patrol cars,
but even after that they couldn’t get anything
of use out of him - he was just shaking and
muttering something about monsters.
Eventually, he was given amnestics to forget
about the incident entirely and recovered.
After the agents reported back to HQ, a new
issue popped up - they weren’t the only
ones who knew about this.
A news website a few counties away had the
story.
The Foundation quickly put out a cover story
- the house had probably been destroyed by
a group of grizzly bears, possibly rabid.
They had the local government issue a warning
advising local residents to stay inside and
out of the wilderness until the animals could
be tracked and euthanized.
And that’s exactly what the Foundation did.
Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6, the Village Idiots
an MTF that specializes in taking on anomalous
threats in remote, rural areas and small towns
- were dispatched to track and contain or
terminate whatever had destroyed that mansion.
The creature had left a strong trail of tracks,
scent, and general destruction, and the troopers
followed it north for hours, into another
dense forest – where they discovered the
gigantic, hulking creature while it was asleep
and shot it.
It was huge, with rippling muscles on all
four legs and no fur to speak of – but the
most striking feature was a frighteningly
human face.
The agents resolved to let the researchers
handle the autopsy, and busied themselves
with the other thing in that forest: there
was an old, abandoned arms factory that the
creature seemed to have come from.
The agents descended into the decrepit, abandoned
building, following the creature’s trail
right into the basement.
There, they found a large steel door, and
behind it, the anomaly that would eventually
be called SCP-4049.
It was strange – it seemed to be some kind
of massive, empty room looking up into the
sky, even though they were deep underground.
Not entirely empty - the dirt ground had a
series of concentric rings of gravestones
in it, all facing inward.
The agents retreated once they realized they
had walked into a spatial anomaly and called
for backup.
The Foundation quickly flew in researchers
and a containment team to figure out what
the anomaly was and to ensure no one else
got into the factory while they figured that
out.
The basement of the factory became a sort
of base of operations for the large crew of
research and security personnel assigned to
SCP-4049.
After making sure there were no other of the
monsters, designated SCP-4049-1 instances,
in the nearby forest, the researchers began
to experiment on it.
They determined that the room on the other
side of the hallway was in an extradimensional
space.
Members of D-Class personnel were sent in
with GPS trackers and even though they could
still be heard fine on the radio, the GPS
trackers failed totally.
Obviously, the fact that you could see the
sky from an underground room was anomalous,
but attempts to dig into where the room should’ve
been from the surface also led to nothing
but more dirt.
From inside, the D-Class members were able
to give a detailed report on the room as they
walked around.
It was perfectly circular and pretty large
- about 30 feet across, give or take.
A tall white wall ringed the room’s border
and was perfectly smooth and impossible to
get a grip on enough to climb – cold, hard
marble.
The floor of the room wasn’t marble, though
– it seemed to be regular dirt.
The D-Classes were ordered by researchers
to get samples of what they could, and they
scooped a little dirt into sample bags.
But as soon as the subjects stepped back over
the threshold into the corridor of SCP-4049,
the sample bags they collected spontaneously
combusted, going up in flames.
Any chemical analysis of its composition was,
of course, impossible.
The researchers resolved to get what information
they could out of just looking at SCP-4049
first.
And there was still a lot to look at.
The D-class inspected the rings of gravestones
inside SCP-4049 – there were just two at
the moment, a larger ring containing a smaller
ring.
Inside the smaller ring, there was a circular
empty space a few feet wide.
Most of the graves were unfilled and unmarked
– just a patch of dirt turned over.
But about a dozen of them had a gravestone
at their head, made of that same white marble
substance the walls were made from.
They weren’t fancy – just a simple white
rectangle, stamped with some strange symbols.
The D-class took photos and sent them to the
researchers, who recognized the markings as
a word in Ancient Greek: “hound”.
The researchers were admittedly baffled by
what this could mean for SCP-4049, but decided
to figure out the connection using the evidence
they had: the corpse of the SCP-4049-1 instance.
The researchers placed the huge corpse inside
the factory, creating a secure space to perform
the autopsy.
Then, a team of doctors began cutting into
it with scalpels - or they tried, anyway.
They quickly realized that the skin of the
creature was far too thick to be breached
with scalpels, and resorted to long, sharpened
knives.
They discovered quite a few things about the
instance's anatomy, along with why and how
it was able to do and absorb so much damage.
It was a quadruped, walking on four limbs.
The forward ones seemed to be in the shape
of arms with elbows and wrists, but also had
clawed paws like a dog’s.
The back legs were thick and heavily muscled,
and digitigrade - again, just like a dog,
so they could be used to leap and jump great
distances.
Once they cut away the skin, the researchers
noticed that it was indeed much thicker than
they expected it to be – human skin is only
about 2mm thick, but this was a full centimeter
throughout, as well as incredibly tough and
gamey.
Internally, the structure was all wrong – it
seemed almost human-like, but with a few key
differences to suit the vastly-changed exterior
body.
The spine was much thicker and wider, as well
as being curved to fit the four-legged structure.
There seemed to be redundant organs – the
researchers theorized they were backups, like
the secondary heart they found inside the
creature’s innards.
It could serve as a backup if the main heart
stopped working or was damaged, or it could
work together with the main heart to improve
the instance’s performance during physical
activity.
There didn’t seem to be any kind of reproductive
system – it wasn’t surgically removed,
it just wasn’t there at all, like it had
magically disappeared.
And inside the thing’s head, the skull was
different.
The mouth was much wider and larger, and it
didn’t take long for the researchers to
figure out why.
When rooting around in its mouth, they quickly
discovered it had an extra set of sharp teeth
behind its main set.
All unnerving, slightly disturbing discoveries,
but the most frightening wasn’t something
they found inside the instance.
It was something they noticed immediately
upon containing it – its face was human.
It had been morphed, of course, to fit the
altered skull, but there were two eyes, a
forehead, a nose, lips – it was inarguably
a human face.
When the researchers sent for a DNA test,
they were disturbed but not surprised to discover
what they had already been expecting: the
instance was entirely genetically human.
Not a changed species or close relative – this
creature had once been a regular human being,
like you or I.
The researchers had just sent the DNA sample
off to check if there was a match in the criminal
database when suddenly, the lights went red,
the doors sealed, and the site’s alarms
began to sound
At that moment, the steel door leading to
SCP-4049 flung open, and another SCP-4049-1
instance bounded out into the corridor on
all fours.
It set its beady eyes on three members of
the Mobile Task Force, standing on the far
side of the long corridor.
For a moment, it didn’t do anything – then
it let out a long screech that echoed around
the entire factory.
Its rear legs tensed up, and it began to bound
down the hallway towards them.
All of the security guards opened fire with
their machine guns on the anomaly, trying
to bring it down.
It shrugged off the bullets like they were
raindrops and didn’t so much as slow down.
Meanwhile, the two dozen other security personnel
in the facility were rapidly grabbing their
weapons and armor from their lockers before
rocketing down the stairs to the corridor.
By the time they made it down, it was too
late – the instance was using its claws
and jaws to tear two of the three poor members
of the Task Force to shreds.
It wasn’t eating them - but it was attacking
them with enough anger and malice that there
wasn’t going to be much left when it was
done.
The third member of the task force had fallen
and was backing away from the anomaly in fear.
The remaining members of the Task Force opened
fire, smothering the SCP-4049-1 instance in
a hail of bullets.
The sudden, overwhelming firepower caught
it off-guard, and after a few seconds of sustained
gunfire, it fell to the ground, dead.
Once the Foundation realized the active danger
that SCP-4049 presented, they decided not
to take any chances with containment.
The 50 meter long corridor leading to SCP-4049
from the basement elevator was fortified - an
airlock was installed on the far side, separating
it from the rest of the factory.
Then motion detectors were set every few meters
throughout the hallway, attached to a series
of ‘deterrents’.
If an SCP-4049-1 instance smashed out of the
steel door, it would trip the alarms and activate
everything from a supersonic sound cannon
to sentry guns and a machine gun emplacement.
And if none of those worked, the entire corridor
could be pumped full of nerve gas, guaranteeing
the death of the instance without risking
the lives of any personnel.
This ‘kill corridor’ was to be guarded
by the Applied Task Force Iota-9 to ensure
that no SCP-4049-1 instance would survive
its escape.
But after the corridor was retrofitted, the
Foundation had a bigger problem: where were
these SCP-4049-1 instances coming from to
begin with?
They performed another DNA test on the new
instance – its face was different, so it
seemed logical that it was a different person.
When the results came back, the researchers
were surprised to find that not just one but
both of the samples had DNA matches in the
national database.
Both were men from the tri-state area who
had mysteriously died or disappeared in the
past few months, while at some kind of religious
service.
They were both avid big game hunters, with
an interest in shooting moose, bears, and
elk.
And most important, they had both been the
subject of a fire-related incident – one
had been presumed dead when his house burned
down.
The other had simply vanished, with his car
being found hours later on fire by the side
of the highway.
In both cases, a body was never recovered
- but the authorities did find a strange stone-tipped
arrow driven into the ground nearby.
Over the following months, the Foundation
observed a number of these strange events
happen in Wyoming, Idaho, and Montana, and
like clockwork, every time it happened, a
new headstone appeared over one of the previously-unmarked
graves inside SCP-4049, saying the same Greek
word: “hound”.
On top of all of that, almost every time a
man in the area disappeared under these specific
circumstances and a grave was created, an
SCP-4049-1 instance would appear inside SCP-4049
sometime in the following two months, buried
within the soil circle in the center of the
room.
It would claw its way out of the dirt, smash
open the steel door to SCP-4049, and race
down the hallway trying to kill and destroy
whatever was in front of it until it was gunned
down.
But in one instance, that didn’t happen.
On September 17th of 2015, the Foundation
had gotten into the rhythm of containing SCP-4049,
so they weren’t startled or caught off guard
when an agent with the Highway Patrol reported
finding a flaming truck near a hunting ground
– in the bed was an elk carcass, with a
stone-tipped arrow lodged deep into the meat.
Applied Task Force Iota-9 at the factory began
to prepare for an imminent appearance from
an SCP-4049-1 entity within the following
weeks, and established a round-the-clock guard
in the kill corridor.
But…
it never came.
By December, nothing had happened at all.
The Foundation made the decision – a D-class
would be sent into SCP-4049 with a camera
and radio, in the hopes of manually initiating
the event to occur.
The D-class subject wasn’t given very specific
instructions - just fitted with a body camera,
a two-way radio, and told to listen to all
instructions on his headset.
The researchers ordered him forward until
he reached the other side of the hallway,
where he was to open the steel door leading
to SCP-4049 and enter.
When he entered, everything looked the same
as the Foundation expected it to - the same
gravestones, walls, and dirt.
He moved towards the center of the room, to
the dirt circle, but suddenly stopped, looking
around.
When the researchers asked why, he reported
hearing the sounds of dogs barking for a moment,
before the researchers told him to keep walking.
When he stopped in the center of the room,
he again radioed in, feeling that someone
was there.
The camera didn’t pick anyone up, but he
insisted that there was an odd feeling, just
before his audio stream suddenly cut out.
A burst of static interference drowned everything
else out, and slowly winded down.
The D-class couldn’t be heard anymore – but
a strange female voice was on the line, speaking
to the Foundation.
She mentioned that the Foundation had been
ruining her pets for far too long.
The Foundation demanded the speaker identify
themself, but she just scoffed, indignant
at what she called ‘human arrogance’.
Right after that, all audio feeds were cut
out permanently.
This mysterious woman was designated SCP-4049-2.
Seven seconds after they cut out, the largest
SCP-4049-1 instance ever recorded exited SCP-4049,
standing at almost 11 meters high.
All of the deterrents were activated, but
even then, it still took all of them combined
with machine-gun fire from the Applied Task
Force to bring the creature down.
No remains of the D-class and no traces of
whoever was speaking on the radio were ever
found by the Researchers.
It can be dangerous to stand between someone
and their beloved pets…
Did you ever have to perform a dissection
in school?
Maybe you had to carve up a fetal pig or slice
into a frog while nightmarish visions of Kermit
and a widowed Miss Piggy danced in your head.
Though it’s rarely a pleasant experience,
unless your tastes are on the morbid side,
most biology teachers would agree that the
best way to learn how something works is to
take it apart.
As distasteful as it can be to hold a frog’s
tiny liver in your hands, it definitely does
give you a better sense of the pieces that
make up the complete creature.
But what if there was an easier way to look
at the individual parts of a living thing?
What if you could take it apart without ever
having to prep a scalpel or stain your hands
with the blood of innocent frogs?
Like most of the seemingly impossible things
in our world, the SCP Foundation discovered
something that allows its users to do just
that.
In fact, it can handle a lot more than just
a frog, and its applications go far beyond
the confines of a high school science lab.
SCP-291 is a small, plain steel building with
a larger door on one side.
The door has no handle or knob, and functions
similarly to a garage door.
The door cannot be pried open by any ordinary
means, and the inside of SCP-291 can only
be accessed if the structure is connected
to a suitable power source.
Once a power source has been connected, the
door raises and exposes the room inside.
It is small, about 4x2 meters.
It contains a console board, a large screen,
and a plexiglass container resembling a coffin.
How very sinister.
The coffin is large enough to contain a human
under 7 feet tall - so sorry, Fernand the
Cannibal, you’re going to need to sit this
one out.
The coffin sits on a conveyor belt, with several
tubes connected to the wall above it.
On the opposite side of the room, there are
holes of varying sizes, each containing a
small door that can be opened or closed.
Because initial observation indicated that
SCP-291 was intended for some kind of human
testing, a D-class test subject was selected
for experimentation.
The subject was instructed to lie down in
the coffin, and wait to see what would happen
next.
The display screen lit up, depicting a grid-lined
image of the test subject.
Buttons along the console board adjusted the
image, showing the skin, muscles, and organ
systems of the person in the coffin.
There were no words or numbers on the screen,
and all of the buttons appeared to have only
two settings: on and off.
When one of the researchers pressed the first
button on the console, the tubes above the
coffin began pouring a blue liquid into it.
The test subject reacted with confusion, but
did not experience any adverse effects.
They quickly lost consciousness, indicating
that the liquid was some sort of sedative.
The liquid continued to pour into the coffin
until the vessel was completely filled, at
which point it congealed into a thick gel.
The test subject’s breathing and heartbeat
slowed to a stop, and the conveyor belt suddenly
creaked to life.
The coffin was carried, test subject inside,
through a small door that immediately locked
behind it.
The small room was filled with the sounds
of gears turning, machinery clinking, and
motors whirring.
The display screen was taken over by a large
rectangle, resembling a traditional “loading”
screen.
After thirty minutes, the process was complete,
and the back door of the room unlocked itself.
When a researcher walked through the back
door, they found another room with a conveyor
belt and a row of two dozen lockers.
Each locker was opened, one at a time, and
its contents removed for examination.
Inside each, the research team found a different
portion of the test subject’s body, in a
block of some unidentified clear substance.
The body was divided in the lockers into these
separate parts: brain, lungs and diaphragm,
heart, digestive system, reproductive organs,
left eye, right eye, upper left torso and
arm, upper right torso and arm, lower left
torso and upper leg, lower right torso and
upper leg, lower left leg and foot, lower
right leg and foot, lower left arm and hand,
lower right arm and hand, neck and head, upper
skeletal system, lower skeletal system, lymphatic
and circulatory system, and skin.
Phew, the miracle of the human body, right?
Boundless in its fascinating complexities...
Each block of body parts was placed back in
its designated locker, and the second button
on the console was pressed.
At this point, the doors to the organ lockers
sealed themselves shut, and the sound of the
machinery working filled the small space once
again.
This continued for a duration of approximately
45 minutes.
When the machinery went silent, a new plexiglass
coffin emerged into the main room, with the
test subject inside.
He looked identical to how he had looked at
the start of the experiment, with no evidence
that he had previously been disassembled.
The blue liquid slowly evaporated from the
container, and the test subject opened his
eyes.
The lead researcher conducted an immediate
interview with the reassembled subject, who
reported no memory of the process after initial
exposure to the blue liquid.
They insisted that the process had been like
a good night’s sleep - which honestly makes
us pretty eager to take it for a spin.
A medical examination determined that there
were only a few changes to the test subject
during the disassembly and reassembly: when
they returned to consciousness, the test subject’s
stomach was empty, they were naked, and all
of their hair was gone.
With this new understanding of SCP-291’s
anomalous properties, the Foundation decided
to continue their experimentation.
With each new test, the experiments became
more creative, and unsurprisingly, more depraved.
First, a D-Class subject was placed in the
coffin and disassembled.
Then, instead of placing the various body
parts in their designated lockers, the vital
organs were removed from their storage before
reassembly was attempted.
This resulted in the equipment shutting down
completely.
A researcher pressed the third button, which
forced a hard reset of the entire process,
causing all of the blocks of body parts to
eject via an exit hatch.
During the next experiment, non-vital organs
were removed before the subject’s body was
reassembled.
The appendix and gallbladder were left out,
and when the subject regained consciousness,
these organs were still gone.
However, there was no visible damage or scar
tissue in their place.
They were simply gone, as if they had never
been there in the first place.
So, if body parts could be removed from a
test subject, could new body parts be added?
Could existing body parts be replaced with
different ones?
A D-class subject in need of a skin graft
following a flamethrower-based accident was
placed in SCP-291.
Once taken apart, a portion of healthy skin
donated by another, somewhat unwilling, D-class
subject was placed in the locker along with
the skin already present there.
Once the subject was put back together, the
healthy skin had replaced the damaged skin
with no adverse effects.
Repeat attempts at this test showed it was
effective for limb transplants, heart transplants,
and kidney transplants, with a 0 percent failure
rate across all tests.
After determining that SCP-291 could be used
for an untold amount of good, making organ
donations easier and safer than ever, the
Foundation naturally had to pivot to something
more useless but interesting and likely horrifying.
After all, it’s not like they could ever
just make anomalous technology available to
the public.
Two D-class subjects, one man and one woman,
were disassembled by SCP-291.
The brains of the test subjects were swapped,
and then they were reassembled.
When they awoke, the subjects had the personalities
and memories of the brain placed in their
body.
In a turn of events previously only seen in
blockbuster comedies like Freaky Friday and
the live-action Scooby-Doo movie, the subjects
had swapped bodies.
They were subsequently disassembled - their
requests to look at their new bodies naked
having been swiftly denied - and the brains
were returned to their rightful bodies.
After the experiment was finished, the subjects
appeared mostly normal.
However, they did complain of disorientation
as well as mental and physical discomfort
over the next several days.
After going through two brain transplants
in one day, though, that’s really the least
you can expect.
After perfecting the practice of swapping
body parts between different human subjects,
the ghoulishly curious research team decided
to take things in an interspecies direction.
A variety of test subjects, including cats,
dogs, lizards, fish, mice, and of course,
humans, were selected for this next round
of experimentation.
Twenty tests were performed using these new
subjects, and only three of the experiments
were successful in transferring body parts
from an animal of one species to another animal
of a different one.
Attempts to swap body parts between mammals
and reptiles or fish proved disastrous.
When a fish and a human were both disassembled,
and the fish’s gills were placed with the
human’s body parts, neither creature survived
the reassembly process.
The human awoke, with a new set of gills embedded
in their neck, and immediately began gasping
for the oxygen they could not take in.
Within minutes, they had suffocated.
The fish’s fate was even worse.
It did not reassemble so much as it became
a pile of goo, scales, and two floating eyeballs.
Experimentation with a human and a lizard
yielded similar results, turning the lizard
into a puddle of organic matter and killing
the human test subject after only a few moments.
As disastrous as the failed cross-species
tests were, the successful ones were almost
as bad.
Trial 001 involved a cat and a human.
Not wanting to attempt too much at once, the
research team opted to just swap out one organ:
the left eye.
Both subjects survived this transfer and were
able to use their new eye.
The human subject reported full use of the
cat eye, with improved night vision in addition
to trouble seeing color.
The cat did not enjoy its new eye nearly as
much as the human subject, and had clawed
its human eye out of its head by the end of
the following week.
In trial 007, a successful brain transfer
was performed between an adult human man and
an English mastiff.
The man in the mastiff’s body expressed
discomfort with walking on all fours, and
asked to be returned to his body as soon as
possible.
The mastiff in the man’s body adjusted to
bipedal locomotion in a few hours, but was
disassembled after urinating on a researcher’s
shoes.
The final successful trial, and the most unnerving,
was trial 016.
A female D-class test subject’s reproductive
organs were swapped with those of a pregnant
Labrador retriever.
An ultrasound conducted after the transfer
indicated that the Labrador fetuses survived
the procedure, and could conceivably be carried
to term by the human subject.
Several members of the research team began
to take bets on whether or not she would end
up giving birth to puppies, but the transfer
was reversed within the day, so we’ll never
know what exactly would have happened.
Perhaps that’s for the best.
Personally, we hope the Foundation’s Ethics
Committee gives some of these scientists a
very stern talking to about their behavior
on this one.
When not in use for testing, SCP-291 is to
be disconnected from any power sources.
At least two personnel are positioned outside
of its containment at all times, standing
guard, and these personnel must be swapped
out every week.
When it is not connected to any power sources,
SCP-291 is considered harmless, though it
should still be treated with caution.
The main entryway remains closed and locked
when there is no available power source, but
the door can be opened manually from the inside
in the event of an emergency.
Any disassembled organisms are stored in a
locker in the containment facility, labeled
with a sharpie marker in order to keep track
of what specimens are stored where.
Whether this is the same sharpie used to label
food in the break room fridge is unknown,
but just like Dr. DiRamio’s ham sandwich,
it’s best to leave these items untouched.
Any personnel found to be responsible for
missing specimens will be transferred to another
project, and receive a strongly worded email.
Hey, do you have a favorite reality show?
Oh come on, don't lie, everyone has one.
Dr. Clef loves some American Ninja Warrior,
and I’ve got it on good authority that Dr.
Bright can’t get enough of The Bachelor,
so how about you, huh?
Do you obsessively follow the romantic highs
and lows of Love Island, or are you more the
type who likes to curl up with a mug of hot
cocoa and enjoy a nice, wholesome episode
of The Great British Baking Show?
Do you ever yell at the TV when the contestants
on Jeopardy just can't get the answer right?
Do you get a kick out of seeing what crazy
collectibles will show up on this week's episode
of Pawn Stars?
If you answered yes to any of these, you're
not alone - Millions of people around the
world still tune in to all kinds of reality
TV.
Personally, I just can't get enough of my
favorite hidden camera show: Laugh is Fun.
What's that?
You've never heard of Laugh is Fun?
Oh, boy.
You're really missing out.
If you like reality TV, you're gonna love
Laugh is Fun.
Laugh is Fun, also known as SCP-2030, isn't
a show that you can watch on TV.
Instead, it appears as the most popular form
of media distribution in the current year.
Today, you can find it on file-sharing and
streaming websites, but in the 2000's, you
could rent it from the DVD kiosk at the mall,
and back in the ‘90s, it used to show up
as multi-tape sets in video rental stores.
Even though the SCP foundation has only been
aware of Laugh is Fun since 1993, it has a
recorded 38 seasons as of 2014, meaning that
it may have existed in some form as far back
as the 1970s.
If you want to binge all 38 seasons, you might
also want to look it up under the names Laugh
is Life, or, in some countries, Laugh is Laugh.
And if you happen to be in a country where
Laugh is Laugh isn’t available, you may
want to try changing your location using a
VPN to one where you can access it… oh,
what’s that?
You don’t HAVE a VPN service?
Well then I’m glad you’re here, because
before we go any further I have a very important
word from our sponsor who just so happens
to be NordVPN, the preferred VPN service of
all the researchers here at SCP Explained,
sign up now at nordvpn.com/SCPExplained .
NordVPN isn’t just a VPN, it’s truly the
BEST VPN available.
With a simple click, you’ll be able access
content that might be blocked just because
of your location, so you’ll never have to
miss an episode of your favorite anomalous
television programs.
But wait, there’s more, much, much more!
What if you’re right in the middle of binge
watch of Season 31 when suddenly your quality
dips to looking like a couple of blurry blocks
are fighting over an old shoebox.
Never fear, because NordVPN encrypts ALL your
traffic.
That means your internet service provider
can’t throttle your service and slow down
your streaming speed.
You should never settle for less than the
highest quality pixels after all.
And it doesn’t matter how you choose to
watch, NordVPN is available on every modern
platform including Windows, iOS, Android,
macOS, Linux, and even Android TV.
The monthly cost is the same as a cup of coffee,
regular coffee that is, not the kind that
comes from SCP-294, and if you sign up by
going to nordvpn.com/SCPExplained you’ll
even get a free month!
So go try it for yourself right now, that’s
nordvpn.com/SCPexplained
Now, back to your regularly scheduled programming.
As we were saying,
Laugh is Fun is a prank show that puts unknowing
everyday people into ridiculous scenarios
and films their reactions.
Each episode is about 10 to 12 minutes long
and features an opening and closing monologue
from beloved, supposedly human TV presenter
Laughy McLaugherson, aka SCP-2030-1.
You've probably seen him before, he's never
seen without his blue three-piece suit and
black wing-tipped shoes.
Funniest guy on TV, seriously, I think he
should replace James Corden on the Late Late
Show.
And maybe even take up a hosting gig on SNL,
if he’s still got time after.
He had this amazing monologue at the end of
an episode in season 32.
“Ha!
What a ride, eh, folks?
We've seen printers that eat, eaters that
print, and everything in between!
Makes you appreciate the old clunker you have
back the office, doesn't it?
No, printers may not always work when you
want or need them to, but they sure make for
some excellent comedy.
And that's what we're about here: comedy.
We're here to make you laugh.
We hope you laughed.
Thank you for laughing with us.
That's what we're about here, doesn't it,
folks?
Come laugh with us again next time!
And remember: LAUGH … IS … FUN!
Good night!
And laugh!
Just laugh!
We love the make laugh.
Make more for laughter so as to for laugh.
Laugh with us.
Laugh with us!
Laugh!
Laugh and let us in!”
Hmmm.
I couldn't tell you what his face looks like,
though, because he's always framed from the
neck down.
Once the pranks are done for the episode,
he'll step up on that bright yellow stage
and deliver his closing monologue, which always
ends with a pan over the audience as everyone
chants “Laugh with us!”
Then the show always just cuts to black.
The closest thing the show ever has to credits
is a title card that says “Filmed in front
of a studio audience in partnership with YWTGTHFT.”
For a show that doesn't advertise or even
air on TV, Laugh is Fun is still a beloved
classic, and when you watch it, it's easy
to see why it's been around so long.
Laughy and the team pull off some really classic
pranks on Laugh is Laugh!
There's this one episode in season 13, where
an unsuspecting family is sitting down to
dinner.
The father starts choking, and the family
reacts with horror, until suddenly a pair
of slits appear on the father's neck, allowing
him to breathe.
Those slits soon become nostrils, and before
you know it, a full second head grows out
of his neck.
That head then grows its own neck, which grows
a nose, then a face, then another head, then
another neck.
This keeps happening a total of 18 times while
the rest of the family looks on in horror.
But don't worry, before things go too far,
Laughy pops out from under the table and tells
the family that they're on Laugh is Fun.
Laughy points out the cameras, and the whole
family starts laughing, including all 18 of
the father's heads.
There's another great season 13 episode called
“Squirrels.”
Oh, man, that one had me in stitches!
Alright, so there's this couple lying in bed,
and the wife wakes up because she hears this
squeaking noise.
She taps her husband on the shoulder to wake
him up, but she draws her hand back in horror
because she can feel something moving under
her husband's skin.
Before she can ask if he's okay, boom!
Hundreds of squirrels explode out of his skin
and start running around the room while the
wife screams.
Then Laughy walks in and turns the lights
on, accompanied by the husband, who is perfectly
okay even though he's been skinned from head
to toe.
Everyone laughs.
Then there's a more recent episode from season
24, called “Swelling.”
There's this old lady sitting on a park bench,
feeding the pigeons, and a couple walks past
her.
While they walk past, the old lady gets swarmed
by the pigeons she's feeding.
The pigeons force themselves into her mouth
and keep swarming until her stomach cavity
bursts open.
The couple, who get sprayed with guts as all
the pigeons fly off, are extremely distressed
by this until Laughy shows up.
Some people say that this episode is too similar
to Squirrels and that the show was starting
to get stale at this point, but I think the
joke is unique enough to stand on its own.
Plus, with a prank show as long-running as
Laugh, it's inevitable that you're gonna see
some jokes get reused.
Really, it's not about the prank itself, it's
about the reactions of the people, which are
always priceless!
And man, the way that Laughy McLaugherson
comes into the frame by climbing out of the
old lady's open ribcage?
I was rolling on the floor!
Oh, you don't think the old “animals exploding
out of people” bit is funny?
That's fair enough.
Let me think - what are some of my other favorite
episodes of Laugh is Fun?
Oh - the Margaret Thatcher episode from season
21!
That's another great thing about Laugh is
Fun, it's not afraid to get a little political.
So, this woman walks into her kitchen and
opens the cabinet, but instead of food being
in there, it's just a big blob of flesh.
The flesh blob rolls out onto the counter
and morphs into a misshapen caricature of
Margaret Thatcher with a disproportionately
big head.
The woman starts screaming, but the Thatcher
creature jumps onto her, pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth.
The deeper the tongue goes, the more Margaret
Thatcher faces start appearing all over the
woman's skin.
All of the faces start reciting Thatcher's
April 1986 speech on the bombing of Libya
in perfect unison.
You might watch it and think the woman's going
to choke based on how long the creature's
tongue is down her throat, but good ol' Laughy
comes in, and the studio audience goes nuts!
Laughy points out the cameras, says “You're
on Laugh is Fun!” and the woman starts laughing
too, with the creature's tongue still in her
mouth.
But I think my favorite prank I've ever seen
on Laugh is Fun was this one from season 37.
So, it's in a hospital.
There's a woman getting a c-section and all
the doctors are gathered around.
One of the doctors makes a comment on how
much hair the baby has, then he screams and
drops his surgical tools.
The rest of the team all start screaming as
well, and then- this is where it gets really
funny- you see Ryan Seacrest's head pop up
out from the woman.
This is causing her a lot of pain, obviously,
so she starts screaming and crying as the
Ryan Seacrest head fully emerges, at which
point you can tell that it's his head on an
octopus' body!
Classic bait-and-switch, right?
But that's not the end- the Ryan Seacrest
octopus starts singing 'Row Row Row Your Boat'
as it emerges, then three more octopi with
celebrities' heads come out of this woman.
There's one that looks like Jack Nicholson,
one that looks like Johnny Cash, and one who
looks like Martin Freeman, and when they've
all come out of her they start singing together
in four-part harmony.
It's hilarious!
Laughy walks in to point out the cameras,
and all the doctors start laughing.
Even the woman on the operating table is laughing.
In fact, she laughs so hard she passes out!
It's a real shame that there are never any
end credits because it would be so cool to
find out more about the people who make this
show.
I mean, they're total comedic geniuses, and
special effects wizards, too.
I couldn't even guess how they do some of
those pranks!
But sadly, there's very little information
about the show online, and you can't even
ask the victims of the pranks about it, because
all of them are dead.
What?
No, no, not because of Laugh is Fun!
That's just a prank show, it's all jokes.
They always show everyone laughing and perfectly
okay at the end, no matter how badly they
got mutilated in the episode.
You can even see some people who had been
on previous episodes among the studio audience
if you look hard enough!
But, by total coincidence, everyone who features
on Laugh is Fun eventually dies, or is already
dead, of totally unrelated causes.
Like the Turman family- the dad, Gary Turman,
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow out
of his neck.
Gary, his wife Lindsey, and their two kids
tragically passed away in a car wreck on the
28th of April, 1989.
Melissa and Travis Englund- the couple from
the squirrel prank went missing and were last
seen on the 12th of May, 1989.
The couple from the pigeon prank- Macey Gersham
and Kyle Parker- were both killed by a hit
and run driver in September of 2000.
Doris Carter, the woman from the Thatcher
prank, passed away from ovarian cancer in
1997, and Rebecca Nash, the woman who gave
birth to all those singing celebrity cephalopods,
died in childbirth in 2013.
You might think that last one had something
to do with her Laugh is Fun episode, due to
the hospital connection, but the surgeons
present when she died didn't report anything
strange happening at the time.
All of these deaths happen in roughly the
same years that all of these people had their
appearances on Laugh, but because it's only
available on streaming and video, it can't
really be said what the connection is since
there aren't air dates for any of the episodes.
While you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on Laugh, and the
show is actually some kind of death curse,
it's just as likely that they died before,
and Laugh is Fun is somehow filmed and distributed
from the great beyond.
Some people even think that the people who
film Laugh actually kidnap all the people
who appear on the show and fake their deaths
in some kind of big sinister conspiracy.
Sure, I have heard that all of the people
who supposedly 'died' after being on the show
have inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually just
hold empty coffins, but still, that feels
totally unrealistic to me.
I mean, come on, can you really picture TV's
own Laughy Laugherson kidnapping anyone?
He has such a friendly attitude!
Like I said before, no information whatsoever
exists about the way this show is made.
Not even the SCP foundation has any answers
- they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on Laugh
is Fun, as well as where it's filmed, and
who produces it.
Talk about a really niche cult hit!
I hope I've sold you on Laugh is Fun.
It may not be that well known, and you might
have trouble finding it, but trust me- it's
the funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch.
I guarantee, once you get into it, it'll make
you laugh, and laugh, and laugh.
Laugh with us!
On April 16th, 1999, the Raleigh Ripper was
finally brought to justice, after a reign
of terror across the state of North Carolina
that left fourteen women dead.
The killer’s true identity had been Kevin
Gruber, a local gas station attendant originally
from West Virginia, who was arrested at work
in the early hours of the morning.
His face was plastered all over the media
when he was cuffed and dragged in to be questioned
and processed.
Like many serial killers, the most frightening
thing about Kevin was the fact that he just
seemed so...normal.
The idea that a person like this could have
committed the atrocities of the Raleigh Ripper
raised a frightening question we all need
to contend with.
What turns a person into a monster?
This question was particularly prescient for
Dr. James Whitington, a criminal psychologist
tasked with conducting the first official
psychological evaluation on Gruber.
Ever since the true identity of the killer
had come to light, the case had held a particular
fascination for him.
Mainly because Gruber The Man and Gruber The
Killer seemed to almost be two entirely separate
people.
According to all evidence, The Raleigh Ripper
was an insidious, methodical criminal genius.
He’d stalked some of his victims - all women
who lived alone - for weeks before striking,
conducting detailed surveillance of their
homes that allowed him to isolate them, bypass
their security systems, and remove any means
of getting help.
He blocked doors, cut phone lines, and always
selected vulnerable targets.
Despite being a seasoned criminal psychologist,
the actual details of Gruber’s crimes had
kept Whitington awake at night.
He had a wife and a young son at home, and
the thought of a man like Gruber prowling
out there made him fear for both of them.
This was no thrill killer - He was a sadistic
torturer, who seemed to delight in the pain
and terror of his prey.
He’d chosen victims he could take his time
with.
Infiltrated their homes like a gust of cold
air through an open window and slipped out
through darkness like a shadow.
Perfectly controlled crime scenes.
No stray evidence.
Nothing but death left behind.
For months, he’d run circles around the
police.
Thousands of people who fit the Raleigh Ripper
profile were interviewed.
Sting operations were conducted.
Communities formed neighborhood watches to
keep each other safe from the killer’s next
move.
And none of it did any good.
From seasoned detectives to legions of beat
cops, nobody could get the jump on Kevin Gruber.
The fact he was even caught came out of pure
chance: A local hiker, Mike Fletcher, just
so happened to hear the screaming coming from
a nearby home in the woods and made the heroic
decision to run in and intervene.
When he walked in on Gruber committing the
attack, the killer panicked, and fled through
an open window.
In his haste, he’d left a partial print
on the window frame.
That, combined with Mike’s description of
the assailant, was enough to finally link
Kevin to the fourteen murders of the Raleigh
Ripper.
The problem, from Dr. Whitington’s perspective,
was that, by all accounts, Kevin Gruber seemed
to be an idiot.
This was no suave, charismatic Ted Bundy type.
In all the prior photos and interviews, Kevin
had that deer-in-the-headlights look of a
man who’s just in way over his head.
Dr. Whitington had also pored over Kevin’s
school records.
The only thing he seemed to excel at was being
mediocre.
He even got held back a year in fifth grade.
Since graduating high school, he’d been
kicked out by his parents for freeloading,
and hadn’t been able to consistently hold
down a job for more than eight months.
His only prior criminal convictions had been
one drunk and disorderly conduct charge, and
possession of an ounce of pot back in 1991,
for which he got a suspended sentence due
to being a minor at the time.
It just didn’t make sense to Dr. Whitington
that this man and the diabolically brilliant
Raleigh Ripper were the same person, despite
all the incontrovertible evidence proving
it so.
Despite his reservations, he needed to meet
this man, and find out why and how he committed
all these horrific murders, despite being
such an unremarkable individual.
Sitting across from Gruber in the secure interview
chamber, Whitington was once again struck
with how incredibly disappointing he was.
Thin and wiry, with glazed-over eyes, messy
hair, and a pathetic tuft of weak stubble
on his chin.
He looked more like Shaggy from Scooby-Doo
than a cold-blooded killer.
His answers to most of Dr. Whitington’s
questions were also insubstantial - with him
often losing his train of thought, or even
needing to ask the psychologist to carefully
explain the question to him.
Most of the time, Gruber tried to make irritating,
slow-motion small talk, concerning everything
from the weather to movies he enjoyed.
The interview had been utterly worthless.
Until, four hours in, Gruber mentioned something
that awakened a strange memory in Dr. Whitington.
He said, “Say, Doc, you remember that TV
show, Bobble the Clown?
I loved that show as a kid.
It was like my religion.
Your kid ever watch it?”
There were a number of unsettling things about
this, from the fact that, for some reason,
Dr. Whitington could remember something about
Bobble the Clown, to the fact that Kevin Gruber
had no way of knowing that Dr. Whitington
even had a kid.
But still, he didn’t let his concern show
and instead asked Gruber what he remembered
about Bobble the Clown.
Gruber smiled, and replied: “Bobble taught
me everything I know, Doc.”
To which Dr. Whitington asked the million-dollar
question, “Like what, Kevin?”
Gruber shrugged and said, “All kinds of
stuff, Doc.
Like how to watch without being seen.
How to jimmy open a window without making
a sound.
How to make ‘em hurt real bad without ‘em
dying, see, so you can make it last longer.
So it can be more fun.
And of course, he taught me to get out without
leaving anything behind.
Bobble made all this possible, Doc.
And he told me all about you, too.
That all this was gonna happen someday.
All good things have to come to an end eventually,
right?
Tell the wife and kid he says hi, by the way.”
Dr. Whitington was astounded.
Gruber seemed to stare vacantly off into space
for a moment, before suddenly claiming that
he had a terrible headache, and he needed
to go back to his cell.
In any other situation, Whitington might have
just written off “Bobble the Clown” as
one of two things - A psychotic delusion,
or a sophisticated psychopath faking a psychotic
delusion in hopes of getting the insanity
plea.
Like the Son of Sam Killer, David Berkowitz,
pretending a demonic talking dog possessed
by Satan made him commit all of his murders.
But Whitington had heard of this Bobble the
Clown before, and it wasn’t in a scenario
that a gas station clerk like Kevin Gruber
ever would have heard of.
It took half a day of research into his own
archived notes to remember exactly where he’d
heard it before: A child he’d interviewed
almost a decade ago, who’d shoved gasoline
and fireworks through the letterbox of an
old woman’s home, leading to a fire that
left the woman and her dog dead.
When Dr. Whitington interviewed the crying
child about his motives, he’d said that
it wasn’t his fault; Bobble the Clown had
told him to do it on the TV.
Given that there were no records of a Bobble
the Clown show ever airing on any local networks,
Whitington had written it off at the time
as the overactive imagination of a very frightened,
very disturbed young child.
That same child would later go into psychiatric
care, before reoffending as a serial arsonist
upon release.
The last building he ever burned down had
only one occupant: Himself.
Fire investigators would later state that
he just sat there, legs crossed, placidly
waiting for the flames to lick his bones clean.
It was becoming incredibly clear that this
“Bobble the Clown” fantasy - if it were
even a fantasy at all - seemed to be much
more than an isolated phenomenon.
He used his credentials to start exploring
other strange crimes of passion committed
by children and young adults, even asking
some of his friends in the criminal psychology
community - off the record - if they’d ever
heard of such a concept before.
Frighteningly, it didn’t take Dr. Whitington
very long at all to hit paydirt.
There was the case of the Orfeo Family Murders
in 1985, out in Arkansas.
Nine-year-old Donnie Orfeo had taken his dad’s
rifle out of the cabinet in the dead of night,
and walked room to room, shooting his mother,
father, and two older sisters in their beds.
Neighbors had heard the gunshots and called
the police.
By the time they arrived at the scene, the
only survivor was Donnie Orfeo himself, drenched
in blood, sitting in front of the TV.
His hollow eyes stared, zombie-like, into
the static.
He did not resist arrest.
When Donnie was taken in for questioning,
his emotional responses were cold and flat.
When he was asked why he murdered his family,
he said that it was because his father told
him he was watching too much TV.
His favorite TV character, Bobble the Clown,
had told him that if he murdered his family
with daddy’s gun, he could watch as much
TV as he liked.
Just reading this, Dr. Whitington could feel
sweat beading on his brow.
Two cases were a coincidence, but three were
a pattern.
And oh, how he wished it had stopped at just
three.
From four days of searching, he’d discovered
no fewer than seventeen different seemingly
isolated crimes with mentions of Bobble the
Clown attached to the file.
A five-year-old boy from New Jersey who’d
drowned his neighbors’ cat in a river with
a gym bag full of heavy stones told police
that he’d learned the technique from Bobble
the Clown.
An eight-year-old girl, arrested for tying
up and torturing her sister with a rusty coat
hanger in Texas, had, of course, gotten the
idea from watching an episode of Bobble the
Clown.
Murder.
Assault.
Vandalism.
Torture.
An extensive, country-wide rap sheet all led
back to that one recurring factor: They all
learned it from watching Bobble the Clown.
Dr. Whitington had gotten in contact with
a few friends who knew people in broadcasting.
While carefully omitting some of the grislier
details, he implored them for any new information
on whether a TV show with Bobble the Clown
had ever gone out, anywhere.
But despite their best efforts, they didn’t
find any records of Bobble the Clown or any
similar educational clown shows airing.
Was it possibly some complex shared hallucination?
Dr. Whitington simultaneously felt burdened
by all this terrifying knowledge, and utterly
powerless to do anything useful with it.
If he started blowing the whistle to the media
or his superiors that a spate of horrible
crimes were all being caused by a violent,
imaginary clown, he’d look just as deranged
as any of the people he’d been studying.
There seemed to be nothing he could do to
stop or help any of this.
He returned home that night with a heavy heart,
hanging up his coat.
He needed someone to talk to about all this,
but he couldn’t burden his wife with the
horrors he encountered daily on the job - Much
less a living nightmare like this mysterious
Bobble The Clown.
As he walked towards the kitchen to pour himself
a stiff drink, he heard strange, jaunty music
coming from the living room.
He stepped back, and saw his seven-year-old
son, Ben, watching something on TV.
As he stepped closer, he could scarcely believe
his eyes.
Ben entranced, eyes fixed on a dancing, grinning,
animated clown on the screen.
Ben slowly turned his head towards Dr. Whitington,
eyes wide and bulging, and said, “I’ve
been waiting for you to get home, Daddy.
Bobble says he got tired of playing with Kevin.
He wants to play with us now.”
Dr. Whitington turned and looked at the clown
on the screen again.
He could swear it was smiling right at him.
That was the last thing he remembered before
the sudden intense headache, and the ground
standing up to embrace him.
When he woke up, he was in bed with his wife,
and neither of them could move - Thanks to
the heavy ropes binding their body to the
frame.
Bobble is very good at teaching children to
tie knots.
They tried to scream, but a shiny flash of
duct tape held both of their mouths closed.
Dr. Whitington’s eyes swiveled in his head
to Ben, standing at his bedside.
The boy was holding a kitchen knife, and he
was very eager to show his mom and dad the
fun new trick Bobble the Clown had taught
him.
To the SCP Foundation, this terrifying anomalous
TV show is known as SCP-993 - Known to cause
blackouts in adults and violent, antisocial
behavior in children.
They do their best to keep the broadcasts
contained, but if ever a child in your life
seems to be acting strangely, perhaps ask
yourself very carefully what they’re watching
when you’re not around...